GOOD WELCOME TO THE MAY ELEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING- TODAY WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR BILLS
THE CONSIDER THIS MORNING AS
PART OF OUR REGULAR ORDERED
HEARING. I WOULD LIKE TO WINNIE
. THOSE UP WE WANT TO WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGGIE JONES
SAWYER WHO WILL BE FILLING IN
FOR MR LEVINE. BEFORE WE BEGAN I
HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES TO
COVER. WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC
TO PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE HEARING BY VISITING
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AT A PRO
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO THE
CONSIDERED PUBLIC COMMENT. A. B.
READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED. ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO
WATCH THE HEARING FROM ITS LIVE
STREAM ON ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE.
ADD A W. W. W. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT GOV TODAY'S EVENTS. THE
HEARING ROOM WILL BE OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING. THE
PUBLIC MAY ALSO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING BY PHONE BY CALLING. 877-692-8957 WITH CONFIRMATION
CODE. ONE EIGHT FIVE. ZERO ONE
ONE ZERO ZERO THAT NUMBER IS
ALSO LISTED ON THE COMMITTEES
WEBSITE. WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC
TO MONITOR THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE FOR UPDATES. WE WILL
ACCEPT PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY
BILL PLACED ON THE SUSPENSE FILE
BY THE COMMITTEE TODAY AND FOR
WHICH THE AUTHOR WAVED
PRESENTATION. BEFORE THE CLOSE
OF THE REGULAR ORDER HEARING
TESTIMONY ON THESE BILLS WILL BE
LIMITED TO A STATEMENT OF NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND
POSITION. ON THE BILL THE
COMMITTEE WILL ALL OUT WILL
ALLOW NO MORE THAN FORTY MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY. RENTS WILL BE
GIVEN TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE IN THE HEARING ROOM. AS
YOU CAME INTO THE HEARING ROOM
TODAY THE SERGEANTS DIRECTED
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE RULES FOR
PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION. WHICH WERE POSTED
OUTSIDE THE DOOR I ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WERE
IN ATTENDANCE TO BE AWARE OF AN
OBSERVER THOSE RULES. PLEASE BE
AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE
RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. WE
WILL LOOK QUICKLY TO SEE IF WE
HAVE A- WE HAVE A RECORD JUST
YET. SO WE WILL WE WILL MOVE TO
A PRESENTATION OF BILLS. THIS
MORNING AND- FIRST UP IS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. BLOOM YOU
HAVE BUT TO BILLS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO NINETY FIVE AND AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR
REMEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE THAT IS A BILL TO HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUILD HOUSING
FOR THEIR TEACHERS AND STAFF THE
MEASURE WOULD MAKE HOUSING. AN
ALLOWABLE USE ON PROPERTIES THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALREADY OWN IF
THE PROJECTS MEET CERTAIN
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS. AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY FIVE HAS NO COST TO
THE STATE I HAVE- DANA COP AS A
WITNESS AVAILABLE- TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS- IF THE COMMITTEE HAS
ANY SHE IS THE DIRECTOR OF CITY
LAB AT UCLA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM THEY
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER THEIR
SUPPORT A TO TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE. WE'LL TURN TO THE HEARING
TO THE OF PHONE OPERATOR.
SUPPORT. FOR TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE. AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IS THERE NO ONE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
ONE TWO ZERO AT THIS TIME. THIS
IS DANA CUFF I PRESS THE-
APPROPRIATE NUMBERS BUT HAVEN'T
RECEIVED INFORMATION FROM THE
OPERATOR YOUR LIFE. THANK YOU MY
DANA KIRKS PROFESSOR DIRECTOR OF
THE UCLA RESEARCH CENTER CITY
LAB OUR STUDIES OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS SHOW THAT EVERY COUNTY
AND EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT HAVE
UNDER UTILIZED LAND THAT COULD
BE DEVELOPED TO THOUSANDS OF
HOUSING ACROSS CALIFORNIA AT NO
COST TO THE STATE. SUPPORT. THEY
WILL BRING IT BACK IF THERE'S NO
OTHER NO ONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT WE DO WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE ET.
LINE EIGHTY GO AHEAD AND YOU MAY
SPEAK. NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
BOB NAYLOR REPRESENTING FIELD
SAID IN COMPANY- STRONGLY
SUPPORTING MR BLOOM'S BILL.
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO SUCH
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THE
NONE. WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- MISTER BLOOM YOUR
BILL IN JUNE AND ENJOYS A DO
PASS- WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT. AND IF THE ROLL CALLS
AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO TAKE
ACTION. YOUR. HOLDEN YOUR
BIGELOW. BRIAN CALDERON VIDEO
DALAI. DAVIES MIKE FONG. VINCE
FONG. GABRIEL EDUARDO GARCIA
JONES SAWYER WORK HERE
ROBERT RIVAS THE- WILSON. WE
HAVE A QUORUM I WILL BRING- ANY
GOMEZ BELL SECOND BEEN MOVED
IT'S BEEN SECONDED OF THIS BILL
IS OUT ON A. B. ROLL CALL. AND
NOW WE'LL HEAR FEWER TWENTY
TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- THIS BILL
MAKES IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE
ELDER CALIFORNIA PIPELINE SAFETY
ACT OF NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE MOVED
WELL ENSURE THAT ALL INTERSTATE
PIPES. REGULARLY INSPECTED.
SAFELY OPERATED MEASURES CRUCIAL
TO ALLOW STATE REGULATORS TO
SAFEGUARD PIPELINE OPERATIONS
AND TO PROTECT THE STATE
COMMUNITIES THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ULTIMATELY THE INTEGRITY OF THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF. IS OUR SECOND
TO THE BILL THE MOTION AND
SECOND MINISTER FONG TO DO PASS
WILL LOOK TO ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT. THE REITER
SUPPORT AT. TWENTY NINE THIRTY
ONE. AND SHE IF YOU LIKE TO
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE ARE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE TO THE
HEARING ROOM ALL ANY OPPOSITION
THE TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE. THEY
NINE PHONE OP. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND IT'LL BE
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE LINE IS FIFTY
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I THANK YOU OUR MODERATOR
MEMBER COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR
JEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL I DO NOT HEAR-
THE- WIND. GET OPENED UP FOR
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY FIVE THE PREVIOUS BILL I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I REGISTERED
OPPOSITION TO THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO NOTED. TWENTY NINE.
WELL AND LINE NINETY. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SH. IT WILL BE COLD TWO
LINE NUMBER. NINETY EIGHT.
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES I MISSED THE FIRST PART OF
THIS IS ON THE RECALL CORRECT.
NO HELLO WE'RE HERE TO YOUR
COMMENTS ON A. B. TWENTY NINE
THIRTY ONE HELLO. AND THIS IS
FOR THE RECALL CORRECT NOTICES.
OKAY AND THEN I'LL PUT MYSELF
BACK IN QUEUE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND LINE NUMBER SIXTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH I NEVER
HEARD ON THE TWENTY TWO NINETY
FIVE REPUBLICAN OPPOSITION TO
THAT. WITH THAT WE'VE DISPENSED
WITH THAT BILL APPRECIATE ANYONE
ELSE WHO IS ON THE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT. BUT WE'VE
MOVED ON WE'RE AT A. B. TWENTY
NINE THIRTY RIGHT I NEVER HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. WE WILL
RETURN. NOT AVAILABLE AT THIS
POINT WE TURN TO THE- PHONE
LINES WHEN THE BILL WAS BEFORE
US WE'VE NOW MOVED ON AND SO
FORTH PHONE OPERATOR IF THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE ONLINE IN A POSITION. TO TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE.
MOVEON REYES NO ONE IN Q. OKAY
WERE BROUGHT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS. SAY
NONE OF THIS ENJOYS A DO PASS-%
WITH ON A- A B. ROLL CALL WITH
MISS DAVIES NOT VOTING. THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS THANK YOU. DR
WOULD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND PLEASURE PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE OH ONE EARLY BEER
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT ON
RESTAURANTS AND THEY ARE ALLOWED
TO SELL DISTRIBUTE THEIR OWN
BEER TO RESTAURANTS BUT THEY'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO SELL DISTRIBUTE
THEIR BEER TO RESTAURANTS THEY
OWN. CURRENT DYNAMIC CREATES AN
ODD OUTCOME WHERE BREWERY CAN.
BRING ITS BEER TO ANY RESTAURANT
TOWN BUT THEY OWN THE RESTAURANT
NEXT DOOR THEY MUST USE A
DISTRIBUTOR. WILL TAKE THE BEER
TO WAREHOUSE OFTEN IN ANOTHER
CITY. YOU FOR BRINGING THE BEER
BACK TO THE RESTAURANT NEXT
DOOR. THIS RESULT IN OBVIOUS
INEFFICIENCIES AND UNNECESSARY
AND WAIT AND WAIT UNNECESSARY
AND WASTEFUL TRANSPORTATION
COSTS AND GHG EMISSION. SIMPLY
ALLOWS MANUFACTURERS TO SELF
TRIBUTE TO THEIR BEER TO
RESTAURANTS THEY ON. YOUR
TESTIFYING BEHALF. IN SUPPORT OF
BEHALF OF THE BILL IS CALIFORNIA
CROPPERS ASSOCIATION. CHRIS
WALKER. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE CHRIS WALKER BEHALF
THAT OFTEN CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION. BOB IS PART OF OUR
PACKAGE COMING OUT TO COPE WITH
THINGS THAT WE'VE LEARNED-
FIXING SOME OF THE
INEFFICIENCIES IN OUR SYSTEM WE
WORKED WELL WITH OUR DISTRIBUTOR
PARTNERS REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION WE- IS. ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION I'M SORRY
SUPPORT. PHONE OPERATOR. WE'RE
TAKING SUPPORT TESTIMONY OR
COMMENTS ON TWENTY THREE OH ONE. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO COMMENT
ON SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY THREE
OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IT'LL BE ONE MOMENT
FOR THAT COMMENT. AND LINE
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NICOLE
GONZALEZ AND I'D LIKE TO RECORD
MINE SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN Q. YOUR IN ROOM
OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY THREE OH
ONE. THE NONE WILL TURN BACK TO
THE PHONE OPERATOR WILL TAKE
OPPOSITION COMMENTS ON TWENTY
THREE OH ONE. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO OPPOSE THIS TWENTY
THREE OLD. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS.
AND THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE BRING IT BACK TO THE
pOUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE. MR
MEDINA.
GOOD MORNING WHAT IS YOUR CHAIR
MEMBERS YOU HAVE THREE BILLS
BEFORE US AS A B. SEVENTEEN
TWELVE WHICH IS THE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS. TWENTY ONE THIRTY
THREE DO PASS AND IT TWENTY
EIGHT. IN ANY ORDER WELL WHEN WE
TAKE. SEVENTEEN TWELVE SEVENTEEN
TWELVE. GOOD MORNING RESENT
SEVENTEEN TWELVE WHICH ALIGNS
STATE LAW WITH FEDERAL OUT
REGARDING SURVEYS OF COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY APPOSITE SAFETY. OR
TO RACIALLY TRIGGERED VIOLENCE
AGAINST API MUSLIM BLACK AND
OTHER STUDENTS OF COLOR ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES OF RISEN BY
ALMOST 57% OVER THE LAST DECADE
. A. B. SEVENTEEN TWELVE WOULD
PROMOTE AWARENESS AND HEL
DEVELOP SAFETY PROTOCOLS FOR
TARGETED STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED- IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE THIS THAN THEIR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. NAY NONE-
PHONE OPERATOR SUPPORT ON
SEVENTEEN TWELVE. AND IF YOU ARE
SUPPORTING AB SEVENTEEN TWELVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AFTER TURN MEMBERS SELL
THE AFFILIATE SHALL BE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN
THE QUEUE. THE HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION COMMENTS ON SEVENTEEN
TWELVE. THEY NINE PHONE OPERATOR
RETURNED BACK TO YOU OPPOSITION
ON. SEVENTEEN TWELVE. AND IF YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO SEVENTEEN TWELVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND LINE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND THERE ARE NO OPPOSITION. TO
SEVENTEEN TWELVE. BRING BACK TO
THE CAN. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THE FREE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
YOU KNOW BECAUSE IS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. THANK YOU I NOT
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE THIRD.
THREE A VERY STRAIGHT BILL THAT
SIMPLY REDUCES THE TIME THE
LAYOFFS WORKERS RECEIVE THEIR-
THERE ARE NEGLIGIBLE COST TO THE
TO OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND
CORE SYSTEM. THANK YOU OTHERS A
MOTION IS- SAID. SINCE OTHER- I
WILL TURN TO THE PO IS- ANYONE
IN THE HEARING. TO LEND A COMMON
OF THE- OWN UP. SUPPORT ON
TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SUPPORT
TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE PRESS
ONES. NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE.
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM
THEY NINE OWNER OPERATOR
OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY ONE THIRTY
THREE. AND IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY ONE THIRTY
THREE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE. MISTER TRIP THANK YOU
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THE
NO COMMENTS WERE THIS BILL IS
OUT DO PASS ON A. B. ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU IN MY LAST BILL AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY. AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY WOULD READ RE
DIRECT THE FUNDS CURRENTLY
INVEST MOVED THE BILL AND CAL.
AND MOVE THOSE FUNDS TO BASIC
NEEDS CENTERS DO NOT HOUSING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
STATE FINANCIAL AID FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
OTHERS BEEN IN MOTION- THIS IS
ON A DO PASS AND SECONDED I WILL
TURN TO THE- THE AUDIENCE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE TO LEND SUPPORT. ON
ME A TWENTY. THE NINE PHONE
OPERATOR SUPPORT ON. TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU HAVE- SUPPORT IN THE TWENTY
EIGHT SHE TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS YEAR MEMBERS
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WHAT THE CO SPONSOR
BILL CONSTRUCTION WORK. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR. OKAY
THANK YOU HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE
WE HAVE ONE QUEUING UP RIGHT NOW
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
AND LINE NUMBER ONE ZERO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SURE HOLDEN REMEMBER JENNIFER
JOHNSON VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
CATHOLIC COLLEGE. SPEAKING TRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WHILE WE'RE AT IT ARE THERE ANY
OTHER- COMMENTS ON IN OPPOSITION
. FOR SUPPORT. ON PHONE LINE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT- OPPOSED THIS TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND IT'LL BE ONE MOMENT.
AND LINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING ARMONK
HEROES HAVE SORRY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE V
TWO EIGHT TWO ZERO THANK YOU.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS NIKKI. SURE THE
STRUCTURE YOU WILL GET AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION IF THERE IS ANY. SAY
NONE WE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THIS IS OUT ON THE
ROLE. WITH DR WEBBER NOT VOTING. BECAUSE THIS IS THE. DR WEBER
NOT VOTING. THE VILLAGE OUT A
ROLL CALL DOCTOR WEBER NOT VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
- THIS BONTA.
YOU HAVE AB TWENTY NINETY ONE
ENJOYS A DO PASS. YOU REPRESENT
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB TWENTY NINETY ONE WILL ENSURE
OUT OF STATE SUBPOENAS WHICH
SEEK INFORMATION RELATED TO A
PATIENT WHO RECEIVED
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT GRANTED AB
TWENTY NINETY ONE ALSO ENSURES
THAT THE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE CAN ENFORCE VIOLATIONS
OF THE RELEASE OF MEDICAL
RECORDS. RELATED TO SENSITIVE
SERVICES I'M ALSO ADDING AN
URGENCY COST OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S NO GAP IN PROTECTION FOR
WOMEN IN NEED OF CARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. INDICATED BY THE
COMMITTEE IN OUT NO COST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO IMPLEMENT AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE AND THE DEPARTMENT IS
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU AND I REFER THEIR SPEC FLEER
QUESTOR I'VE FOUGHT TO MOVE THE
MOVE THE BILL. SENATE THE
PROMOTIONS AND NOW SECOND. DO
YOU HAVE MOLLY ROBSON SHE'S JUST
GOING TO DO A ME TO READ OKAY
VERY GOOD SO WILL TURN TO THE
HEARING ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. MORNING TOMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MOLLY
ROBESON WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
MONTH ON THE BILL AND SHOWING
SUPPORT THE- GOOD MORNING
GENESIS GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
ATTENDED GOVERNOR LENNY CLOCK IS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THEY KNOW
WHETHER A PHONE OPERATOR WILL
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT OF- ZERO NINE ONE TWENTY
NINETY ONE. ALL RIGHT AND IF
YOU. HAVE ARE IN SUPPORT THESE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AB. TWO ZERO
NINE ONE. M. LINE NUMBER FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING AS A ARE ON THE OF THE
COLOR NURSES WITH THE XIN NY
RAPPER TO CAL OF THE YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU WILL TURN TO THE HEARING
ROOM OPPOSITION. THE TWENTY
NINETY ONE C. NINE OWNER
OPERATOR SORRY OPPOSITION. MY
NAME IS DENISE AGUILAR CO
FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS AND
PRESIDENT OF SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
LIBERTY COALITION AND OPPOITION. THANK YOU SEEN NO OTHERS WILL
TURN TO PHONE OPERATOR.
OPPOSITION THROUGH TWO ZERO NINE
ONE. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
OPPOSED TO ZERO NINE ONE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND LINE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CANARY YES. I AM
MY NAME IS MONICA AND AYE
OPPOSED. TWENTY NINETY ONE.
THANK YOU. AND LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS LINDA BUCHNER AND I'M A
PART OF THE RECALL MOVEMENT I
OPPOSE TWENTY NINETY ONE. AND
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES HI GOOD MORNING
CHALLENGER MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SHARON A LATCH- SPEAKING BEHALF
OF CHANCE RALLY RUNNING FOR US
SENATE. AND- AND FOR PROSECUTING
. WHERE IT'S WRONG. OF THIS BILL
WE ARE NOT A POINT WE ARE NOT AN
ABORTION MAIL THANK YOU SO JUST
TAKING THINGS SUPPORT.
TRANSITION WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE- AND THAT LINE IS NUMBER
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING CARE PROTO RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AMBASSADOR FOR LEXINGTON
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS THE
COKE. I'M A PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. A
LINE NUMBER SIXTY FOUR AIRLINES
OPEN. YES MY NAME'S GLENN THE
MEASURE AND IMPACT THE COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND LINE
NUMBER FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FIFTY HI MY NAME IS.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. THERE CAN NOW.
HI MY NAME IS CAROL AND MEDINA
ALAMEDA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
TWENTY NINETY ONE THANK YOU. N.
NEXT LINE ONE ZERO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS RACHEL
CAN FOUNDER DETERMINES YOU READY
FOR FREEDOM AND WE OPPOSE. AND
LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YEAR LINES OPEN. HI THIS IS
GABRIELLE INGRAM FOUNDER AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE DO NOT
SUPPORT THAT PLEASE VOTE NOW.
AND LINE NUMBER SIXTY SIX
AIRLINES OPEN. MY NAME IS
VANESSA FONG AND WE HAVE AYE
OPPOSED TO FILL. AND LINE NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS STEPHANIE SALINAS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND LINE NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINES OPEN. I'M PRO CHOICE
I'VE HAD TWO ABORTIONS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AIRLINE NUMBER
ONE ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EVEN AND I AM A CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN IN AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL
TWENTY NINETY ONE. AND LINE
NUMBER TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI MY NAME IS ELAINE FROM A
PLAN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR OR
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE DOCTOR WEBER. THE MORNING I
JUST WANNA REALLY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR IN CALIFORNIA DO ALL
THAT WE CAN'T REMOVE ANY
OBSTACLES THAT WOMEN THAT EITHER
LIVE HERE ON A STATE MIGHT HAVE
IN TERMS OF SEEKING- THE RIGHT
TO CHOOSE WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
WITH THEIR OWN BODIES AND THOU
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND
PRODUCT SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
. NO OTHER COMMENTS BONTA IF YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. AB TWENTY NINE IS
A NECESSARY BILL TO COMBAT THE
WAVE OF ABORTION RESTRICTIONS
BEING ENACTED. ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THE BILL PROTECTS EVERY
PERSON'S FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. MAKE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH DECISIONS.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR VOTE. GOES OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. THANK ARAMBULA. MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WILL BE WAVING
PRESENTATION ON ALL ITEMS ON
FILE WITH THE EXCEPTION OF AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN TODAY. AB
TWENTY FIFTH TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN MINIMIZES THE CHANCE
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
ATTENDING A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. WILL BE DEAD NAMED BY
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS FACULTY
AND STAFF CAN DESIGNATE THEIR
AFFIRMED OR CHOSEN NAMES AND
PRONOUNS. ASK FOR MY BOOK. THANK
YOU. NO WITNESSES OKAY WE'LL
TURN TO THOSE WHO ARE IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM TO OFFER
THEIR SUPPORT. I MEAN MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA CO
SPONSORED THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING GENESIS
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR LENNY CLOCK IS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
. RETURN TO THE PHONE LINES ANY
ONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
THEIR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN. HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
RING IT BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION A TWO TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN. SEEING NONE RETURN BACK
TO YOUR PHONE OPERATOR FOR ANY-
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
THEIR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION.
TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN IF YOU ARE
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN PRESS ONE
ZERO. AN ONLINE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I CAN HEAR ME. THE
MORNING CAN'T- MY NAME IS
VERONICA AND I AM CALLING TO
OPPOSE. TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN
THANK YOU. AND LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS LINDA BUCHNER AND THEN
FROM FOSTER COUNTY I AM INDIAN
IN OPPOSITION AND SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF EVERY GOD FEARING
INDIVIDUALS LIKE A- WEIRD MOVE
ON THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT.
AND LINE NUMBER SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
RANDOM AND SUCH A COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND LINE
NUMBER NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS STEPHANIE. AND
I COMPLETELY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND LINE NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
MONIQUE FROM WHAT YOUR PARENTS
FOR CHOICE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. AND LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SURE IN A LARGE REPRESENTATIVES
RALLY RUNNING FOR US SENATE AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSES DON'T. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE THANK YOU. WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU DR AND- BRINGING THIS ON
BAIL AS A MOTHER OF A
TRANSGENDER CHILD IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPACT SMALL FOR OTHERS BETTER
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE DEBT NAME
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. AND
REALLY SPEAKS TO THEIR OWN
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL BEING TO
BE ABLE TO BE CALLED BY THE
RIGHT NAME EVERY SINGLE TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DR EMILY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THAT
AMOUNT AS MY CLOSEST FRIEND OKAY
THIS BILL IS OUT. ON A IS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. ARE
NOT VOTING. ACCORDING.
ZERO ONE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
VAN PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE THE BILL TO
IMPLEMENT THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION THAT STATE
ENTITIES NOT UNDER THE CONTROL
OF THE GOVERNOR BOB THE BASIC
SECURITY CYBER SECURITY
STANDARDS WHILE THIS BILL IS
GOING INTO SUSPENSE TODAY I WANT
TO POINT OUT THE FINANCIAL
INCONSISTENCIES THAT HAVE
PLAGUED PRIOR VERSIONS AND THE
CURRENT BILL WELL CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS. OF WHO WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ADOPT THE STANDARDS
HAVE TOLD POLICY COMMITTEES THAT
THEY ALREADY MEET ALL
CYBERSECURITY STANDARDS THEY
PROVIDE COST ESTIMATES TO THIS
COMMITTEE. AS IF THEY DO NOT
HAVE ANY SECURITY AT ALL THIS
YEAR SUBMISSION FROM THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ESTIMATES
THE NEED FOR SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND THIRTY EIGHT
NEW POSITIONS TO ADOPT BASIC
STANDARDS INCLUDED IN THIS BILL.
THESE COST ESTIMATES THAT SEEM
DIVORCED FROM REALITY LAST YEAR
AS OF LAST YEAR FOR A VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL BILL THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE ESTIMATED. THAT WOULD
COST BETWEEN A HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE AND 300-405-0008 TWENTY
FOLD INCREASE WITH NO CHANGE AT
ALL TO THE BILL. THIS IS AFTER
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE HAD A
BCP AND LAST YEAR'S BUDGET FOR
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT WAS JUSTIFIED BY THEIR NEED
TO CONTINUE TO MEET THESE
STANDARDS. I COULD GO ON WITH
OTHER EXAMPLES OF THE CALL.
OFFICERS PLAN AND WITH THEIR
ESTIMATES ON THIS ISSUE LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WHOSE
ESTIMATE LAST YEAR OF THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
BALLOON TO ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION THIS YEAR. BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY MY MESSAGE TO
THIS COMMITTEE IS SIMPLE YEAR
AFTER YEAR THE AUDITOR AND THE
INDEPENDENT THREAT REPORTS HAVE
MADE CLEAR THAT EVERY STATE
AGENCY NEEDS TO HAVE MINIMUM
CYBERSECURITY STANDARDS IN
PLACE. WE ARE FAR PASS A TIME TO
BE. ASSESSMENT GAMES WHEN THE
STATE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO BE
DOING THIS WORK REGARDLESS OF
THE COST. IS THAT AT THE END OF
THE DAY OUR ADVERSARIES. LIKE
RUSSIA OR VULNERABILITIES AND WE
ARE ONLY AS STRONG AS OUR
WEAKEST SYSTEM IT WILL BE OUR
FAULT WHEN THE CALIFORNIA'S
FINANCIAL SYSTEMS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEMS AND ELECTORAL
SYSTEMS FAIL. BECAUSE WE DO NOT-
BASIC CYBER SECURITY STANDARDS
FOR THESE IMPORTANT STATE
ENTITIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THIS IRWIN. AND WE
WILL LOOK TO ANYONE WHO IS HERE.
TO LEND THEIR- COMMENTS OF
SUPPORT AROUND THE BILL EVEN
THOUGH IT IS ON ITS WAY TO
SUSPENSE. SEEING NONE I WILL
TURN THE PHONE LINES. ANYONE
ONLINE AND I'LL I'LL SAY IN THE
BEFORE WE GO TO ONLINE OF
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. WE'RE OUT OF THE
PHONE LINE WILL LOOK TO
ENTERTAIN ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO OFFER THEIR THOUGHTS OR
COMMENTS. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS. TWENTY
ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND LINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- ISRAELITE CHURCH
EVERYTHING DUE TO BRADLEY
RUNNING FOR US SENATE AND WE
AGREE WITH THE SPEAKER ON THE
SPELLS. AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU-
SO WILL. OF A DECISION ON OUR
SUSPENSE CALENDAR AND WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO. SEEING WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU. THE ORDER. OKAY OKAY. THE SIMPSONS PRIZES
BERMAN WAS THE. RIGHT OKAY MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY FOUR WHICH
INCREASES FINES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO EMPLOY MORE THAN TEN FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES AND GIVES JUDGES
DISCRETION REQUIRE THE CONVICTED
INDIVIDUAL TO PAY FOR REMOVAL OF
ILLEGAL DUMPING ILLEGAL DUMPING
IS A SERIOUS OFFENSE THAT IS
CONTRIBUTING TO LOSS OF
COMMUNITY PRIDE AND DECREASES
PROPERTY VALUE INCREASES
COMMUNITIES ON THEIR ABILITY TO.
CRIME THE GARBAGE ILLEGALLY DUMP
POSE A SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS ON
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES AND
TAXPAYERS ARE CURRENTLY LEFT
WITH PICKING UP THE TAB. AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FOUR
PROVIDES COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS TO COMBAT ILLEGAL
DUMPING AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY FOUR HAS MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE COST TO BOTH THE
COURTS AND STATE AGENCIES. WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WE HAVE SOMEONE ON THE
LINE IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY- ANYONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM I'D
LIKE TO OFFER THEIR SUPPORT.
THROUGH AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
FOUR. NAY NONE PHONE OPERATOR WE
WILL ENTERTAIN SUPPORT ON TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY FOUR AND- WE HAVE.
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS- MISPLACED
HER. AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
FOUR PRESS ONE ZERO. IN LINE ONE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HM
THAT'S THE FORTY CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD IN SUPPORT.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN THE QUEUE MANAGER CARE THANK
YOU HEARING ROOM OP A SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION. THE NINE PHONE
OPERATOR WILL TO ENTERTAIN ANY
COMMENTS OR THOUGHTS ON THE
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY FOUR. MANY OPPOSITIONS
TO AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FOUR
PRESS ONE ZERO.
THERE ARE NO OPPOSITION WILL BE
Q. AT. THANK YOU BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS A DO PASS
AS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED THERE
WILL BE NO COMMENTS IT'S OUT ON
A ROLL CALL THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. ALL RIGHT MR BERMAN.
YOUR MOVES AN EMAIL. I WOULD
ALWAYS HAPPILY DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE- SUMMER FRIEDMAN BUT
THIS ENSURING COLLEAGUES GREAT
TO SEE A- AS CALIFORNIA CRAFT
BREWERIES FIND THEMSELVES
COMPETING FOR CONSUMER AWARENESS
TASTING ROOMS WHICH UTILIZE
DUPLICATE LICENSES OUR PRIMARY
MEANS TO INCREASE BRAND
RECOGNITION IN THE CONSUMER
FOLLOWING. AB TWENTY THREE OH
SEVEN WOULD ALLOW THE NUMBER OF
DUPLICATE LICENSES HELD BY A
BEER MANUFACTURER TO GROW FROM
SIX TO EIGHT AND THE NUMBER OF
THOSE THAT CAN BE USED FOR
BONAFIDE EATING ESTABLISHMENTS
TO GROW FROM TWO TO FOUR. AS A
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES THERE
SHOULD BE A MINIMAL FISCAL
IMPACT ON THE DEPARTMENT OUT
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WITH ME IS QUICK- CHRIS
WALKER ON BEHALF OF THE-
CALIFORNIA CRAFT VERSUS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRUCE COMMITTEE CHRIS
WALKER BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
CRAFT BREWERS ASSOCIATION THIS
IS THE SECOND OF TWO BILLS
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR TODAY THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO OUR CRAFT
BREWING INDUSTRY. I LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR CARRYING
THE BILL THIS YEAR ALSO I'D LIKE
TO THINK THE- I CALIFORNIA BEER
DISTRIBUTORS FOR WORKING WITH US
TO REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION- ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL
TURN TO. UP MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM SUPPORT
. C. NINE OWNER OPERATOR WILL
HEAR SUPPORT ON TWENTY THREE OH
SEVEN. AND SUPPORT. FOR TWENTY
THREE OH SEVEN PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE NONE IN
THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR WELCOME
BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION. TWENTY THREE OH
SEVEN. YEAH I DON'T SUPPORT THIS
BILL SUPPORTING THE BILL BY
SOMEBODY'S SWEARS UGLIEST ESTA
WE'RE GOING TO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. THEY WILL TURN TO
PHONE OPERATOR. OPPOSITION AB
YOUR ARE IN OPPOSITION OF TWENTY
THREE OH SEVEN PRESS ONE ZERO
LINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I DON'T SUPPORT LAWMAKERS
SWEARING AT THE PEAK. OPERATOR
THERE ANY OTHER COMMENT THERE
ARE. THERE ARE NO OTHER COMMENTS
REGARDING ROGER THANK YOU WE'LL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AS A MOTION SECOND TO DO PASS.
NOT ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU
JOHN COLLEAGUES. FRIEDMAN. MOVE
THE BILL. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AB TWENTY
NINETY SEVEN IS A GOOD HOUSING
BILL AND A STRONG PROPERTY
RIGHTS BILL THAT HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT- THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW
DEVELOPERS THAT ARE BUILDING
CLOSE TO HIGH QUALITY TRANSIT TO
DECIDE HOW MUCH PARKING THEY
NEED FOR THEIR DEVELOPMENT I HAD
THE BILL STILL REQUIRE. MOMS FOR
ALLEGED PARKING AND DISABLED
PARKING UP BUT GIVEN THAT ON
AVERAGE A GARAGE COST BETWEEN
TWENTY FOUR AND THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER SPACE TO
BUILD WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO RIGHT SIZE THE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR RESIDENTS WHO
OFTEN HAVE ONLY ONE CAR IN SOME
CASES NO CARS TO OFFER THOSE
UNITS TODAY FOR LESS MONEY IS A
GREAT WAY TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND INDEED
WHEN SAN DIEGO AND THEIR
DOWNTOWN DID VERY MUCH THIS POP
. THE AMOUNT OF AFFORD HOUSING
THAT PRODUCE INCREASED FOUR
TIMES. SO THIS IS A BILL THAT
MAKES SENSE AND HELPS TRANSIT
WORK IT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO SELF
SELECT WHO DON'T HAVE CARS TO
HAVE LESS CARS. IT'S SUPPORTED
BY A WIDE RANGE OF BUILDING
GROUPS ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND
HOUSING ADVOCATES. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ANY
OPPOSITION AND WITH THAT I WOULD
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN A
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM AND
SUPPORT. THE PORT OF AB TWENTY
NINETY SEVEN. PHONE OPERATOR
WILL TURN TO SUPPORT TWENTY
NINETY SEVEN. AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINETY
SEVEN PRESS ONE ZERO AND LINE
NUMBER THIRTY SIX YOUR LINES
OPEN. MORNING MR CHERILUS MANTE
CALLING IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE ONE OF THE BILL'S
PROUD CO SPONSORS THANK YOU. AND
LINE NUMBER ONE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MICHAEL AND
WHISPER BILL CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOR
AND LINE NUMBER FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WITHOUT OUR QUOTE
ON BEHALF OF SINGLE PROPERTIES
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND FOR THE QUALITY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS KELLY FACT I
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT
THEM. AND THEREFORE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU WILL TURN TO THE
HEARING ROOM FOR OPPOSITION. THE
TWO ZERO NINE SEVEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK THE
NO OTHER IN THE HEARINGROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER OFFICE
SUPPORT I'M SORRY OPPOSITION.
WILL TURN TO THE PHONE LINES.
OPPOSITION. TO TWO ZERO NINE
SEVEN. AND IF YOU ARE OPPOSED TO
AB TWO ZERO NINE SEVEN PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
VERONICA AND I'M CALLING
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWO ZERO
NINE SEVEN THANK YOU. AND LINE
NUMBER ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN I APOLOGIZE I MISSED
THE PREVIOUS Q. HI MY NAME IS
CHRIS WILSON WITH THE L. A.
COUNTY BUSINESS PREPARATION WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. OF A P. AB TWO
ZERO NINE SEVEN THANK YOU. AND
ONE MOMENT HER NEXT COMMENT. AND
WHEN I AND NUMBER THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
I APOLOGIES FOR I'M THINKING
THIS IS ACTUALLY FOR THE COURT
AND EIGHTY TWO ZERO NINE SEVEN
MONEY TO STATE THAT IT ON BEHALF
OF A YUPPIE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE FOR NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WE HAVE A
MOTION THE TO DO PASS WE NEED A
SECOND. MODIN SECONDED. THIS
REMAINED WHICH YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
. THIS BILL HAS REALLY NOMINAL
IF ANY COST TO THE STATE SO I
WOULD REQUEST TO ALLOW IT TO
MOVE THROUGH. NOT ON A B. ROLL
CALL WITH MR FONG. MR COOLEY IF
YOU CAN JUST GIVE US A SECOND TO
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO DISPENSE WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- SO WE CAN.
SO THAT. THANK IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED- TO ADOPT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WILL TURN TO. A
SECRETARY TO READ THE CONSENT.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE ASSEMBLY BILLS AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE MEDINA
SEVENTEEN FIFTY SEVEN HANEY
SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO MATHIS
TWENTY FORTY FOUR- DONALD.
TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT HANEY TWENTY
NINETY SIX MULLIN TWENTY ONE OH
ONE FLOOR AT TWENTY ONE THIRTY
CUNNINGHAM 217-410-2350 FIVE
SALAS TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT
O'DONNELL TWENTY FOUR SEVEN-
DONNA TWENTY. FIFTEEN LACKEY
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE HOLDEN
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
CARILLO. TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
BAO QUE HAN 28-7 YEAH BONTA
TWENTY NINE OH FOR ME A BONTA
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FIVE COMMITTEE
ON LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT TWENTY
NINE FIFTY SIX COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION TWENTY NINE SIXTY
ONE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE MANY ON.
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY THREE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
WITH HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I. BIGELOW
BIGELOW I BRIAN HI BRIAN I
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE KOREA
MEGAN DOLLY MEGAN DOLLY I DAVIES
DAVIS I MIGHT FONG MIKE FONG I
VINCE FONG. APRIL GABRIEL I
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER I
QUOTE. HI BOOK I ROBERT RIVAS
WEBER. WEBER I WILSON WILSON I.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
NOW TURN BACK TO MR COOLEY
YOU'RE PRESENTING ON THE
SUSPENSE. SENATE BILL TWENTY
EIGHT NINETEEN. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I OF COURSE
WAVE ON THE OTHER BILLS I WANT
TO TALK AB TWENTY NINETEEN WITH
THIS GROUP. ON YOU KNOW WE'RE IN
A TIME WHEN THERE IS A GREAT
DEAL OF DIVISION IN OUR STATE IN
OUR NATION. AND I THINK. AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS. THE ALL
IMPORTANT THING IS HOW DO WE
MAINTAIN A WORKABLE CENTER HOW
WE WORK TOGETHER THE GOVERNANCE
OF THE STATE AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN IS TAKES
NOTE OF THE FACT THAT LAST TIME.
ARE FINANCED LOOKED AT OUR
STATE'S FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
TWENTY EIGHT OF THEM WERE
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING ZERO GROWTH
ARE ACTUALLY SHRINKING. YOU TEND
TO BE OUR MORE RURAL COUNTY. AND
WE IN THE STATE ACTUALLY HAVE A
LONG HISTORY. OF THE STATE LEVEL
CREATING TOOLS TO SUPPORT LOCAL
INITIATIVES IDENTIFY ISSUES YOU
WANT TO WORK ON THE NEED TO WORK
ON. THIS IS A INFRASTRUCTURE
BANK WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY
AUTHORED BY MARIAN BERGESON AND
STEVE PEACE REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT
WORKING TOGETHER CREATED A
FUNDING MECHANISM. THIS BILL
TAKING NOTE OF THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE SUCH AN EXTRAORDINARY FLOOD
OF REVENUE. PROPOSES THAT WE
SHOULD SET ASIDE EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. FOR COMPETITIVE GRANTS
THE COULD BE ACCESSED IN
COUNTIES UNDER MY SPECIAL
DISTRICTS INDEPENDENT FAR
DIFFERENT. A LIKE A VOLUNTEER
FIRE DEPARTMENT I HAVE WILTED
AND ERROL. AND ARE COUNTIES
UNDER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND. TO
FOCUS PRIMARILY ON PRIMARILY ON
DISASTROUS. BUT THAT COULD BE
FACILITIES THAT COULD BE
UPGRADING OF FACILITIES IT WILL
BE A SHELTER IN PLACE A VENN
FIRES LIKE THE AMADOR COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS- AND ALSO ROAD
PROJECTS WHICH WOULD BE
IMPORTANT KIND OF EGRESS FOR.
VIRGIN IT DOES REQUIRE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF THIS
PROGRAM IN THE AYE BANK. WOULD
BE PAID BY UP FRONT FEES OF
PETITIONS THOSE LOAN PROGRAM
WOULD HAVE TO PAY FEED I. BAKED
WOULD COVER THE DISTRICT COURT.
THIS PROGRAM. BUT IT WOULD
ESTABLISH A SYSTEM OF
COMPETITIVE GRANTS. TO FUND
THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS AND IN
THAT SENSE I THINK IT IS IT IS
AN AIR OF SO MUCH WHAT WE'VE
DONE WHERE YOU KNOW. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT YOU HAVE PEOPLE
DEVOTED TO THE WELL BEING OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES. A FUNDING
STREAM IS REALLY A WAY TO
RELEASE LOCAL ENERGY ON THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS. IT REQUIRES
THAT ANY PROJECT LOCALLY THESE
FUNDS COULD ONLY GO 250% OF THE
PROJECT COST WHAT DOES REQUIRE
DEVELOPMENT OF PARTNERSHIPS TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD. I ACTUALLY
THINK THIS IS A- IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE NOTE OF THE
CHALLENGES OF OUR RURAL COUNTIES
THE UNUSUAL. REVENUES ARE
PRESENT AVAILABLE AND YOU KINDA
LOOK ACROSS THE STATE TO SAY
ACTUALLY THIS IS A TIME TO FILL
ORDER STEP UP AS A STATE TO
SUPPORT OUR MORE RURAL COUNTIES
WHO ARE CHALLENGED BY THINGS AND
OF. TO PROVIDE SOME FUNDED THEM
GET BUSY CONTACTED LOCAL FIRE.
ARM IT IS A BILL SUPPORTED BY OR
C. SACK ALLEN'S OF CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRE DISTRICTS OF CALIFORNIA
THE FIRE CHIEFS OF CALIFORNIA
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS. AND AS I
SAY I ACTUALLY THINK THIS IDEA
IS DESIGNED TO KIND OF BUILD
UPON THIS ACTED VERY AND
BURZYNSKI POTTER SO LONG AGO.
WHO REQUIRE PARTICIPANTS TO KIND
OF COVER THE ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERHEAD. BUT BEYOND THAT
PROVIDE FUNDING THAT COULD
SUPPORT THE SORTS OF THINGS I
THINK LARGER COUNTIES WILL FIND
WAYS TO PIECE TOGETHER VITAL
PROJECTS THIS IS REALLY TAKING
NOTE OF THE CHALLENGING TIMES OF
A RURAL COUNTIES. I THINK IT
WOULD BE A- GREAT THING FOR ALL
OF US I DO NOTE THAT WHEN I WAS
AN OFFICER OF THE LEAGUE. OF
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER BROUGHT
MEASURE B. THE STATEWIDE BALLOT
WHICH IS FUNDING FOR. ROADWAYS
AND A GUARANTEED EVERY CITY AND
COUNTY AND STATE HAD FUNDS.
SOBRE WHEN WE DID PROP TWENTY
ONE WE TOOK CARE OF FUNDING. FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE. AND EVERY
JURISDICTION. THIS IS AN IDEA
THAT DEMONSTRABLY IS POPULAR
WITH CALIFORNIA. AND OKAY THIS
IS SORT OF. A FIX FOR SAYS THERE
IS A TIE THE FIRST ABANDONED
HERE CAPTION OF RIDES ON VICTORY
WE HAVE A LOT OF REVENUE. I
THINK ALLOWS US THE LEGISLATURE
TO TAKE SOME STEPS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT. A BILLION
DOLLARS IS A BIG NUMBER BUT I
THINK THIS YEAR. HI THIS WAY-
IT'LL BE TO OUR CREDIT AND WE
WON'T MISS. WE KNOW IT WILL BE
PUT TO GOOD USE. THE RESPONSE
ALSO A INCREASE IN FIRES A
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT SAID I JUST
TAKE THE PROVINCIAL THIS BUSY
MORNING. A TO TAKE YOUR TRYING
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND. PICTURE
WORSE THANK YOU- ON THE SUSPENSE
SIX ADDED BILL WILL ALSO TAKE
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT. FOR OPPOSITION.
ORDER UP MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WEREN'T SUPPORTED THIS
EFFORT RECEIVE THE DIALOGUE WITH
THE MEMBER WE LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING ONE FINAL ROUND OF
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE IN THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL LOOK
TO THE PHONE LINES OWNER
OPERATOR WE ARE TAKING. COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN. AND IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN
PRESS ONE ZERO LINE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE GREAT HI
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU I'M SO
GLAD YOU'RE ALIVE WE WILL LOOK
FOR YOU. THREE WEEKS. NO STORM
SORRY WE'RE HAPPY TO SEE HIM TOO
BUT WE'RE JUST GOING TO TAKE
COMMENTS OR YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL
ORGANIZATION IF ANY. OKAY WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN SUPPORT.
THIS. AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE MISTER
CHAIR THANK 
YOUR COMMENTS THIS MORNING AS
ALWAYS THEY'RE LIMITING AND-
THIS IS SUSPENSE COUNTED BILL SO
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO. FINO GOES
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU I MISS
REYES. RESENTING AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY. THERE WAS A DO PASS. MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY STEP WHICH IS A GOOD
NEIGHBOR POLICY FOR LOGISTICS
DEVELOPMENTS AND IN RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES. THE LOGISTICS
SECTOR IS CLEARLY A ONE THAT
FEELS THE NEED FOR EVERYONE TO
CALIFORNIA BY ENSURING THE GOODS
MOVE TO THEIR INTENDED
DESTINATION NO ONE DISPUTES THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF LOGISTICS.
AND THAT CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER
IN THE SECTOR. HOWEVER THE
LOGISTICS SECTOR SPECIFICALLY
WAREHOUSES SHOULD BE GOOD
NEIGHBOURS TO THE COMMUNITIES
THERE IN. IN MY COMMUNITY AND
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WHERE HOUSES ARE BEING BUILT
RIGHT NEXT TO HOMES AND SCHOOLS
THAT INCREASES THE RISK OF
HEALTH PROBLEMS FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. MORE WAREHOUSES A
MORE LARGE TRUCKS DRIVING IN AND
OUT OF PREDOMINANTLY BLACK.
LATINO IMMIGRANT AND LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE THE
FACILITIES ARE LOCATED. AS EARLY
AS TWO THOUSAND FIVE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD RECOMMENDED A
BUFFER ZONE BETWEEN RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS AND WAREHOUSES. IN
MY DISTRICT IN THE COMMUNITY
BLOOMINGTON SIX OUT OF EIGHT
SCHOOLS. ARE LOCATED OR WILL BE
LOCATED. RIGHT NEXT TO WHERE
HOUSE. AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
PROVIDES THAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO
BUILD OR EXPAND A LOGISTICS
FACILITY OF ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET OR MORE. IT MUST
HAVE A SET BACK ONE THOUSAND
FEET FROM SENSITIVE RECEPTORS
WHICH INCLUDE HOMES SCHOOLS
HOSPITALS DAY CARE CENTERS
COMMUNITY CENTERS. IT ALSO
ALLOWS ALTERNATIVES TO THE
SETBACK REQUIREMENT IF THOSE
ALTERNATIVES WOULD PROVIDE THE
SAME LEVEL OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AS A ONE THOUSAND
FOOT BUFFER ZONE. WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO LEND THEIR SUPPORT A TO
A B. TWENTY EIGHT FORTY. THEY
NINE PHONE OPERATORS SUPPORT ON
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY. AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND LINE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CURTIS LANG THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
THANK YOU. AND LINE NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN. HI
MY NAME'S NICOLE FOR SADDAM
SAMBAR DINO I MEAN FOR THIS BILL
. AND LINE NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
IN MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. OWNER OPERATOR
ONLINE OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY. IN OPPOSITION FOR
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY PRESS ONE
ZERO AND LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD
MORNING ADAM REGULAR BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION LABELED
AS A JOB KILLER THANK YOU. AND
LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING CARE
NUMBERS CHANGED DIRECTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LABORS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
AND LINE NUMBER NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. STEPHANIE SO
A LOT AND I AM COMPLETELY
OPPOSED TO THIS IT IS A JOB
KILLER. ANALY NUMBER SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN OPEN- GOT ME.
YES IT IS I THINK OKAY MY NAME
IS VERONICA AND I'M CALLING IN-
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL TO EIGHT
FOUR ZERO. AND LINE NUMBER ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS REX W.
HI MY BEHALF CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION NAP
CHAPTERS OF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OWNERS AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND I TNC OPPOSED
TO THIS ONE SIZE FITS ALL A BILL
THAT WILL ACTUALLY TURN ARE
SWIRLING JIM OUTLOOK. AND OUR
NEXT QUESTION IS FROM LINE HER
COMMENT IS FROM LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY I MISSED THE LAST- FOR
SUPPORT SO I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT I SUPPORT THIS BILL. VIRGIN
GROUP AND LINE NUMBER SIXTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS SAM FROM TRACTOR CONNIE AND I
OPPOSE. AND LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TILEFISH
RENO ARCH THANK YOU TO RALLY
RUNNING FOR US SENATE AND WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION AT AB TWO
EIGHT FOUR ZERO AND WE WOULD
APPRECIATE A KNOW ABOUT THANK
YOU. AND LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
LINDA FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. ALL AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
MISTER CARE. THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SAYING NO
COMMENTS THE BILL WAS OUT ON THE
B. ROLL CALL. THANK YOU. A THIS-
BRIAN.
MOVE THE BILL. IF YOU'RE
ENTITLED TO THAT THE THOUGHT OF
. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ARE RISING TO PRESENT AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE A BILL
THAT MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
OUR STATE'S DEFINITION OF
STUDENT BLANK INSURANCE COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES PURCHASE DIDN'T
BLANK INSURANCE POLICIES TO
PROVIDE HEALTH BENEFITS TO THE
ENROLLED STUDENTS CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA CHARACTERIZE BLANKET
POLICIES IS THE TYPE OF
DISABILITY INSURANCE RATHER THAN
AS INDIVIDUAL HEALTH PLANS
DESPITE FEDERAL LAW. LABELING IT
AS SUCH AS RESULT STUDENTS AND
THEIR DEPENDENTS WHO RELY ON
INSURANCE THROUGH THEIR COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY ARE NOT ENTITLED TO
BENEFITS SUCH AS LIMITED COST
SHARING ROB TO PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS OR TELEHEALTH SERVICES. AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE WILL FIX
THIS. BY REDEFINING STUDENT LIKE
INSURANCE COVERAGE THAT PROVIDES
HOSPITAL MEDICAL. AND SURGICAL
BENEFITS AS A TYPE OF INDIVIDUAL
HEALTH INSURANCE. THIS WOULD
BRING THESE POLICIES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE MANDATES
RELATED TO INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
INSURANCE- THE BILL ANALYSIS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ESTIMATED THIS BILL WILL HAVE
MINOR BECAUSE IT'S RECEIVED BY
PARTISANS. THUS FAR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO LEND SUPPORT.
TO THIS BILL. OWNER OPERATOR
WILL TURN TO YOU EIGHT A. B.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE SUPPORT.
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SUPPORT A.
B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE PRESS
ONE ZERO AND LINE NUMBER ONE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EACH. ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I CHANGED MY MIND. THANK
YOU. AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE MISTER
CHAIR. OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THEY NINE PHONE OPERATOR
OPPOSITION ONLINE. FOR EIGHTEEN
TWENTY THREE. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS VERONICA AND
I'M CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. A LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M LINDA
FROM PLASTER COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. AND YOUR LINE NUMBER ONE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHEN THE COMPRESSOR PARTY ARE
OPPOSED. AND LINE NUMBER NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THIS IS STEPHANIE STRELA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AND LINE NUMBER
ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. YES MY NAME IS NICOLE YOUNG
FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND ARNOLD
WERE KNOWN FOR THEIR COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE. MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE NO COMMENTS THE
BILL IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU MISTER. MISTER CALDERON. YOU
HAVE TO BILLS TO PRESENT TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO DO PASS AND
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX ALSO
DEPEND.
THANK YOU WITH. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ACTUALLY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SEVEN ACTUALLY IF
YOU CAN MAYBE PULL THE MIKE DOWN
A SET UP BETTER OKAY MOVE THE
BELL ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO WOULD ALLOW FOR
PERSONAL INSURERS THAT DO NOT
SHARE PERSONAL POLICY HOLDER
INFORMATION FOR MARKETING
PURPOSES TO SEND OUT THE PRIVACY
POLICY ONLY IF IT HAS CHANGED
THIS BILL SEEKING TO REMOVE A
REDUNDANCY IN EXISTING LAW.
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF UNNECESSARY
PAPER WASTE GENERATED TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT IS SAMANTHA CORBIN ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY DR
QUICK SECOND BY. MISS WILSON.
AND SO WILL HEAR YOUR WITNESS
TESTIMONY. THEY WERE NOT HEARING
YOU THOUGH. STILL GETTING USED
TO NEW EQUIPMENT HOURS MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD MORNING MY
NAME SAMANTHA CORBIN I SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA THE SPONSOR OF TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO THIS MEASURE
IS AT ITS HEART A FEDERAL
CONFORMITY BILL THE GRAMM LEACH
BLILEY ACT OR G. LBA IS A
FEDERAL LAW CONTROLLING PRIVACY
NOTICES THAT MUST BE SENT TO
CONSUMERS BY INSURERS. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE JAIL BE A WITH
AMENDED TO PERMIT INSURERS TO
SEND NOTICES ONLY WHEN THEIR
POLICIES CHANGE TO ELIMINATE
CONFUSION FOR CONSUMERS IN
ADDITION TO THE JAIL BE A
CALIFORNIA HAS A NUMBER OF OTHER
STRONG PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AND
NOTIFICATIONS WITH WHICH
INSURERS ALREADY COMPLY
INCLUDING THE INSURANCE
INFORMATION PRIVACY ACT OR AYE
IPA. IN SPITE OF THESE
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY THREE
REMAINING STATE TOOK. TWENTY
FIVE. TO THE VLBI AS A RESULT
INSURERS MAIL HARD COPIES OF
MILLIONS OF REDUNDANT DOCUMENTS
TO CONSUMERS EVERY YEAR. NOT
ONLY DOES TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
TWO LEAVE THE AYE AYE PA INTACT
AMENDMENTS NEGOTIATED IN THE
ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY STRENGTHENED ITS
PROVISIONS TO REQUIRE HYPERLINK
ACCESS. TO ALL CURRENT PRIVACY
POLICIES IN THE REQUIRED ANNUAL
ABBREVIATED I A P. DISCLOSURES
FOR EASE OF CONSUMER ACCESS. THE
MEASURE MAINTAINS CLEAR AND
THOROUGH PROTECTIONS WHILE
REDUCING REDUNDANT INFORMATION
FOR CONSUMERS IN FACT REPEAT
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THE
LONGER THE DISCLOSURE AND THE
INCREASED FREQUENCY OF
DISCLOSURES. CAN ACTUALLY
CONFUSE CONSUMERS AND THAT THEY
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BOTH READ AND
UNDERSTAND THEM WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT BY PROVIDING EASE OF ACCESS
TO THE MOST MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION AND HIGHLIGHTING
CHANGES AS THEY OCCUR. THE
CONSUMER CONFUSION WILL BE
DECREASED AND WE ASKED TODAY FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IS ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO WIN
SUPPORT ON TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
TWO. THING PHONE OPERATOR WE
WILL BE TAKING TESTIMONY OR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO. AND IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO PRESS ONE ZERO. AND LINE NUMBER ONE YEARS
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS WHEN THE PLASTER CONNIE
I SUPPORTIVE. AND THEREFORE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU COME BACK
TO THE HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION.
WHEN A THREE SEVENTY TWO. NAY
NONE PHONE OPERATOR OPPOSITION
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO. AND IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND IT
WILL BE ONE MOMENT HER COMMENT.
AND WHY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOING TO OPPOSE THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IT'S
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. THANK YOU.
NOTE YOU CAN PRESENT- AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- MOVE THE BILL AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SIX WILL PROTECT
ABORTION PROVIDERS FROM HAVING
THEIR LICENSES REVOKED OR
SUSPENDED OUR RESPECTIVE
PROFESSIONAL BOARDS FOR LAWFULLY
PROVIDING OR COORDINATING
ABORTION CARE WITHIN CALIFORNIA
OR ANOTHER STATE. THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
THANK YOU WILL TURN TO THE- TO
THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SIX. HELLO AGAIN
GENESIS GONZALEZ ON BEHALF
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ILINYKH A
LOCK IS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS DENNIS QUESTO
MATTER WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
SAY NO OTHER TO LEND SUPPORT AND
THE HEARING ROOM WILL TURN TO
THE PHONE OPERATOR. SUPPORT ON A
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX. AND LINE
NUMBER FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WELL IT'S ABOUT ARE QUITE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEAR
NORTH DISTRIBUTION IN EUROPE
CORRECTLY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND LINE NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- HELLO- MY NAME IS ALAN
FACT I REQUEST THE. AND LINE
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JONATHAN GO
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER TRICKLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND THERE
ARE NO FAR FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
YOUR IN ROOM IS THERE ANYONE TO
. BEACON OPPOSITION. THEY NINE
PHONE OPERATOR OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY SIX TWENTY. A LINE NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT AIRLINERS ON. YES
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE SALE AND I
DO. AND LINE NUMBER SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK MORNING
MY NAME IS VERONICA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX. AND LINE
NUMBER ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS BRENDA
MEASUREMENT PATRICK HANEEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND
LINE NUMBER FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL GO TO
THE NEXT LINE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI I AM LISA
ALTMAN FROM ORANGE COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS. AND LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS AMBER
DELLA CREWS FROM ORANGE COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. IN LINE
NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS LINDA
BUCHNER AND I AM FROM PLASTER
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE. AND
LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS JENNY
GREEN FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AND LINE NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS SERRA I'M A
NURSE- IN BUTTE COUNTY AN
INTERPRETER HEALTHCARE WORKERS
FOR FREEDOM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. AND THERE ARE
NO FAR FURTHER COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
WE'RE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THE
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS IS OUT
ON A. B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR TANG. AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FIVE. YOUR PASSES THE
RECOMMENDATION MOVE THE BILL
THAT AFFECTS THE MOST MATURE LET
ME JUST THANK YOU IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK ON THE
BILL THE BILL IMPRINT REFLECTS
AMENDMENTS THAT TAKEN IN
ASSEMBLY TO IS AN ENERGY THAT
ADDRESS CONCERNS IN THE
OPPOSITION. THE BILL EMPOWERS IS
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
TO REALLY DEVELOP EXPERTISE FOR
COST EFFECTIVE YOU BE CHARGING
STATUS FOR ALL BUILDINGS AND
WORK IN COOPERATION WITH THE
PART OF HOUSING COMMITTEE
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION THE STATE
ARCHITECT. AS WELL AS THE- EVERY
SOURCES WITHOUT RESPECT
RESTAURANTS THANK YOU OUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL YOU'RE IN
THE HEARING ROOM SEEING NINE
WILL TURN TO THE- REITER. PORT
ON A. B. TWENTY SEVENTY FIVE. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FIVE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
THERE ARE ARE NO COMMENTS THE
HEARING ROOM OF A COMET IN
OPPOSITION. THEY NINE PHONE
OPERATOR WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION. AND LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI MY NAME IS VERONICA AND I'M
CALLING TO OPPOSE TWENTY SEVENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. AND WHAT I
NUMBER ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS LINDA
MUSTARD PLASTER COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND LINE
NUMBER NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS STEPHANIE SO A
LOT AND I REALLY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. AND LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS WORTH ABOUT THEIR IN
POCKET JOHNNY I STRONGLY OPPOSE. AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THEY NINE MISSES OUT ON THE B.
ROLL CALL. AFTER MUCH. MR FONG.
THE BILL. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN WILL REPLACE EVERY
STATUTORY REFERENCE THAT
OBSOLETE BAY DELTA CONSERVATION
PLAN THE MULTI SPECIES
CONSERVATION PLAN THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW RELEVANT GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES TO CREATE MULTI SPECIES
CONSERVATION PLANS WITHOUT
CHANGING ANY LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS THE
BILL HAS NOT NEGLIGIBLE THEY
COST ASSEMBLY ASPIRIN AYE BUT-
THANK YOU ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO LEND
THEIR SUPPORT TO EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN. SAY NONE OF. WE WILL
TURN TO THE PHONE OPERATOR
ANYONE ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN ELEVEN. AND IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN ELEVEN
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR. HEARING
ROOM OPPOSITION. SINAN PHONE
OPERATOR WILL ENTERTAIN
OPPOSITION ON EIGHTEEN ELEVEN.
THE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS VERONICA AND I'M CALLING
TO STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT AB
EIGHTEEN ELEVEN THANK YOU. AND
LINE NUMBER ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS BRANDON
FASTER COUNTY NYSTROM THE OPPOSE
. AND LINE NUMBER NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES STEPHANIE
SUELEN AND I REALLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND LINE
NUMBER ONE ONE FIVE ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
LINDA BUCHNER AND PLASTER COUNTY
I JUNE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND MR JOURNAL BE ONE MOMENT
FOR OUR NEXT COMMENT. AND LINE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
SONORA AND I ADMIT THE QUEUE BUT
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OUR VICE CHAIRMAN
BIGELOW. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF THE AUTHORED I WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR. LISTEN TO MY
QUESTIONS AND POLICY COMMITTEE
AND- HEARING THOSE QUESTIONS IN
FACT- YOU YOU WERE VERY OPEN TO
TAKING AN AMENDMENT AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR ENTERTAINING
THAT DISCUSSION AND I'D LIKE TO
CLARIFY YOU ARE GOING TO TAKE-
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO YOUR
BILL. LATER ON THE FLOOR. WELL
IT'S NOT HERE BEFORE US TODAY IT
WILL BE WORSE ON THE FLOOR IS
THAT CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT
THANK YOU SO MUCH I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT AS YOU
AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT AND
OTHER MEMBERS MAY NOT HAVE THE
SAME KNOWLEDGE. OF THAT TODAY
ABILITY MYSELF OR TO YOUR BILL I
DON'T KNOW THAT ALL REPUBLICANS
ARE AS COMFORTABLE AS THAT YET
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO SEE THAT IN THEM AT
WORK WITH YOU ON IT. BUT I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
WILLING TO WORK ON AND- ON.
MAKING THIS A BILL MORE WORKABLE
AND I WANT TO THANK. EIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE- I. SEE NO
OTHER COMMENTS THIS BILL IS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AND
BIGELOW ON. THANK YOU.
RIVAS YOU CAN- FLOOR'S YOURS TO
PRESENT FOR MR GRAYSON ON AB
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE. AND AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES IN MORNING US WE'LL
START WITH NINETEEN THREE FIVE
IT WAS THE BILL GRAYSON ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON- THIS LEGISLATION
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE IS A DISTRICT BILL WHICH
SEEKS TO FACILITATE THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF CONCORD NAVAL
WEAPONS STATION BY ESTABLISHING
PROCESSES UNDER WHICH THE CITY
OF CONCORD MUST CERTIFY THE
PROJECT THE IR THE DECIMATED THE
PROJECT WILL CREATE TWELVE
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS SIX
MILLION SQUARE FEET OF
COMMERCIAL SPACE. AND WILL ALSO
CREATE TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
PERMANENT JOBS AND A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY I'M THEIR ON SITE THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION RESPECT
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU WILL TURN TO THOSE IN THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO. REDDIT
THEIR SUPPORT FOR A BI NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE
TURN OF THE PHONE LINES SUPPORT. FOR NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE. YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE NINETEENTH
AB NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO
ONE HAS QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
C. NINE WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES OPPOSITION FOR NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE IF ANY. YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. BY
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE CLEVELAND AND I LIVE
NEAR THE BASE FOR MANY YEARS I'D
LIKE TO KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO BE
CLEAN OUR LETTING. BUT I AM
ORGANIZATION ALL YES I AM. I AM
. I ABOUT OH GOD THANK YOU. IN
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS VERONICA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE- NEED AB NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY FIVE.
HI MY NAME ISMICHAEL ARE YOU ON
I STRONGLY OPPOSE- NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE. ONE NINETY. HI THIS
IS MIKE WHEN WAS BIRTH SORRY I'M
LATE BUT I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. ONE
SIXTY FIVE. MY NAME IS JASMINE
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL. ONE SIXTY SIX.
LINDA FROM PLASTER COUNTY I
OPPOSE. MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU IT WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. YOU KNOW
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW
QUESTIONS THE BILL IS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING DAVIES
AND FONG AND I. WE WILL NOW HEAR
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY. HE WANTS AND
THAT'S A DO PASS. AGAIN ON
BEHALF ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
THE BILL TWO ONE SEVEN ZERO SIX
TO GIVE MORE CALIFORNIA'S THE
CHANCE TO OWN A HOME. BY
ENSURING THAT WE GIVE OWNER
OCCUPANTS AND PUBLIC ENTITIES A
FIRST LOOK AT PURCHASING BANK
OWNED PROPERTIES IN BY
PROHIBITING BULK SALES OF
FORECLOSED HOMES MEASURES
MODELED AFTER THE FEDERAL
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY'S. FIRST
LOOK PROGRAMS WILL INCREASE THE
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERSHIP. AND
CALIFORNIANS STOCK OF ABOUT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INSTEAD OF
ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
FRANCE FOR RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES TO CORPORATE
OWNERSHIP FOR RENT THROUGH THE
FORECLOSURE PROCESS- THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WAS
PASSED OUT OF. THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ON CONSENT. I JOIN US
OVER THE PHONE THIS MORNING TO
TESTIFY IS JENNIFER. BACK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
REALTORS THAT THE ASPEN I VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU YOUR
WITNESS NOW. GIVEN THE NUMBER
AND SHARE- AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER STACK ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE'RE PROUD TO PARTNER
WITH THEM IN NUMBER GREAT SAND.
ON THIS- MONUMENTAL PROPOSAL I
WE COULDN'T HAVE SAID IT BETTER
THAN THAN THE PRESENTATION YOU
JUST RECEIVED RESPECTFULLY ASK-
I HAVE A- THANK YOU PHONE
OPERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE ONLINE
I WOULD LIKE TO WIN SUPPORT ON
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY. AND THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ANYONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
. THEN NINE OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. A NON OF MADAM
OPERATOR TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
ANYONE ONLINE FOR OPPOSITION. NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE THEY WERE
VERY BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. OKAY
THEN THE BILL IS OUT ON IN A
ROLL CALL. RESOLUTION ON. AND
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTEEN SO- FINAL
BILL ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SEVEN ONE THREE L. SEEKS TO
UPDATE THE SAFETY TRAINING FOR
RIDE SHARE DRIVERS REQUIRED
THESE DRIVERS TO BE TRAINED- OR
TO RECEIVE SAFETY TRAINING EVERY
TWO YEARS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ALREADY
REQUIRES COMPANIES LIKE UBER
LIFT TO PROVIDE SAFETY TRAINING
TO THE DRIVERS HOWEVER THE C. P.
U. C. DOES NOT SPECIFY WHAT THAT
TRAINING MUST INCLUDE- SO THIS
MEASURE WILL CERTAINLY HELP
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF PASSENGERS
DRIVERS AND PEDESTRIANS ALIKE.
SPECT WE ASKED WE ARE AYE VOTE
MR THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THEY WOULD LIKE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES SUPPORT.
COMMENTS ON TWENTY SEVEN SIXTEEN. THERE ARE NO COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR OPPOSITION IN
THE HEARING ROOM. OWNER OPERATOR
OPPOSITION ONLINE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION WE NEED. GIVE ME JUST
A SECOND. OKAY ME JUST A SECOND
PHONE OPERATOR WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM YEAH MIKE AND
ONE OF THE PEOPLE AB FIVE
DISTRACTED- DRIVER AND THEN I
DON'T SUPPORT THIS BILL. PHONE
OPERATOR. WE'LL GO BACK TO THE
PHONE LINE ON TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTEEN OPPOSITION. AND THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR THE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS ON A ROLL CALL. ARCO.
WE'LL HEAR FROM YOU NOW YOU HAVE
A- A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE
ENJOYS A DO PASS. SECOND. THANK
YOU ON A WHEELCHAIR I AM HERE TO
BRITANNIAE BE SIXTEEN THIRTY
THREE AB SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE IS
AN INFORMATION SHARING BILL
BETWEEN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS IN OUR CALIFORNIA
VETERANS ADMINISTRATION OR CAL
THAT. ALL TOO OFTEN OUR VETERANS
ARENOT AWARE OF THE BENEFITS
THAT WE EXPAND OR CREATE EACH
YEAR HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
WITH THE VAST NUMBER OF VETERANS
ATTENDING HIGHER EDUCATION IN
OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS. THIS
BILL WILL HELP CONNECT VETERANS
WITH THEIR WELL EARNED BENEFITS
THE BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON CONSENT
THROUGH HIGH RED COMMITTEE AND
MIL THAT OUR MILITARY VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO LEND
THEIR SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND FOR
NOW. MY NAME IS DR TERESA CONAN
I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX
THREE THREE. THANK YOU. THREE
LAUNCH A SUPPORTING JAMES
BRADLEY FOR US SENATE AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK. RICHARD GATES
ORANGE COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE THANK YOU.
OWNER OPERATOR WILL TAKE SUPPORT
ONLINE FOR SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE. AND IF YOU ARE SUPPORT
SUPPORTING AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
THREE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THE SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE SEE NON
OR OPERATOR WILL TAKE OPPOSITION
TO SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE ONLINE.
AND THERE ARE NO COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME THE STRUCTURE. THE NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS ON A ROLL
CALL. THANK YOU. WE'RE. THEY'RE
PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO
AND TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE BOTH
ENJOYED TO PASS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ARE PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE OH
TWO AND THANK YOU FOR MOVING
BEFORE I. GO TO WHICH BILL IT
WAS- AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO UP
FINES FOR ILLEGAL CANNABIS
OPERATIONS- AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO
WHICH WILL HELP IN THE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET BY ALLOWING TO
DEPARTMENT CANVAS CONTROL THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO ASSESS UP TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY.
ON A PROPERTY OWNERS WHO
KNOWINGLY PERMIT THEIR ILLEGAL
BUSINESS IS THE OPERATE THIS
BILL HAS MINOR AND ABSORB IT
WILL COST TO DOJ TO BRING ACTION
AGAINST PROPERTY OWNERS THEY'RE
IN VIOLATION AS WELL AS
POTENTIAL LOW COST TO OUR COURT
SYSTEM NICK STAFF WORKLOAD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
WIN SUPPORT. A TWO TWENTY ONE OH
TWO. THE NUN PHONE OPERATOR
SUPPORT FOR TWENTY ONE OH TWO.
AND THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE THE STRUCTURE OF ANYONE
WHO OPPOSES WHO'S IN THE HEARING
ROOM.
THANKS MIKE ONE OF THE PEOPLE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. HI GOOD DAY.
RACHEL GATES ORANGE COUNTY
OPPOSED TO ONE OR TWO. THEY WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES OPPOSITION. AND THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE SHARE THEY WERE VERY
BACK TO COMMITTEE SAYING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS THIS IS
OUT THIS BILL IS ON A ROLL CALL
. EIGHT TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE
ALSO DO PASS MOVE THE BILL. I AM
I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY FIVE WHICH ENSURES
THAT CANNABIS IS TREATED JUST AS
ANY OTHER LEGAL SUBSTANCE FOR
THE PURPOSES OF CHILD CUSTODY
AND DEPENDENCY COURTS THIS BILL
DOES NOT A REPEAT DOES NOT
CHANGE THE CHILD WELFARE
INVESTIGATION PROCESS OR ANY
PROCEEDINGS ASSEMBLY REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
WHO OVERSEES INVESTIGATIONS. TO
ENSURE THAT ALL REGULATIONS AND
GUIDANCE GIVEN TO COUNTIES TREAT
CANNABIS THE SAME AS ALCOHOL.
LEGALLY PRESCRIBED. THIS HAS
MINOR ABSORBED WILL COST TO D.
S. S. TO UPDATE REGULATIONS AND
PROVIDE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IF
NECESSARY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU SUPPORT FOR
TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. IT'S. MY NAME IS
DR TERESA KERN I'M IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FIVE NINE FIVE. THANK YOU
. GO TO THE PHONE LINES SUPPORT
FOR TWO FIVE NINE FIVE. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE HEARING ROOM. OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPPOSITION TO TWENTY FIVE
NINETY FIVE. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE THE
STRUCTURE THEY WERE VERY BACK TO
THE COMMITTEES NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. THIS IS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH DAVIES NOT VOTE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS COMMITTEE.
RIVAS IF YOU LIKE TO. RESENT
YOUR BILLS. AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
TWO WHICH IS TO PASS. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SEVEN FOUR TWO SIX A
STRAIGHTER CLARIFY THE EXISTING
TOBACCO DIRECTLY STATUTE TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S OBLIGATIONS UNDER
THE MASTER SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE MSA
LEGISLATION RESULT IN IN FIRST
ENSURING OUR STATE RECEIVES ALL
PAYMENTS OWED BY THE TOBACCO
COMPANIES THROUGH THAT MSA. AND
SECOND TO HELP REDUCE THE RISK
OF NON FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES FROM
ENTERING THE MARKET THIS- THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THIS BILL
EXPECTED TO BE MINOR AN
ABSORBABLE I'M WITH US THIS
MORNING BY PHONE TO HELP ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ARE JENNA STANFORD
AND BURY ALL THIS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL-
BONTA I RESPECT THAT'S WHAT
I'VE- THANK YOU. WE'LL TURN TO
THE HEARING ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
HERE AND SUPPORT. OF THE
SEVENTEEN FORTY TO SAY NONE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES PHONE
OPERATOR SUPPORT ON SEVENTEEN
FORTY TWO. AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
THE HEARING ROOM. OPPOSITION. TO
SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO. PHONE
OPERATOR WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES AND IT TAKE ANY THE TAKE
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO. THERE ARE
NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE A VERY
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. OF SEEING
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS THIS
BILL IS OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL
. OUR NEXT BILL- ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE EIGHT EIGHT TWO IS AN
IMPORTANT TRANSPARENCY MEASURE.
WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS ARE INFORMED ON THE
SEISMIC READINESS OF LOCAL
HOSPITALS AND ENSURE THE
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR PATIENTS.
WITH A MAJOR SEISMIC EVENT OCCUR
IT WAS BILL DOES NOT IMPOSE ANY
NEW SEISMIC SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
ON HOSPITALS. IT'S SIMPLY
IMPROVES THE COMMUNITIES
KNOWLEDGE OF HOSPITAL'S SEISMIC
RADIUS SO THAT EVERYONE IS
PREPARED IN CASE EMERGENCY DOES
OCCUR. THIS COMPACT OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS BACK TO BE MINOR
AND ABSORB ALL THE STATE A WITH
ME HERE TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IS JANICE O'MALLEY. OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
THANK YOU MR. THANK YOU. HELLO I
AM MEMBERS O THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN JANICE ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
GRATEFUL TO REMEMBER RIVAS WE
ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
AND HAPPY. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM ELECTED IN SUPPORT.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO. A PHONE
OPERATOR WILL TURN THE PHONE
LINES FOR SUPPORT ON EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU OPPOSITION IN
THE HEARING ROOM. AFTER AN OFTEN
SCOUT CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR
IS RELATED TO THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WE STILL HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT OUR HOSPITALS
REPORTING ON A REQUIREMENT THAT
THEY- HAVE DIFFICULTY MEETING IN
THE TWENTY THIRTY REQUIREMENT
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE ISSUES
RELATED TO THE REPORTING. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE. THROUGH EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. AND MISTER KERR
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE WE NEED A
MOTION FOR- THIS IS A DO PASS
THE SECOND. AND WE HAVE A
QUESTION FOR DOCTOR WEBER. GOOD
MORNING I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE STARTING TRANSPARENCY IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE ALL
OF OUR RESIDENTS ARE SAFE
ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME OF
EMERGENCY. I AM VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT. THE FACT THAT IT IS
OPPOSED ONLY BY CJ BUT PRETTY
MUCH THE MAJORITY OF THE
HOSPITALS IN MY AREA. SO I WILL
SUPPORT IT TO GET OUT OF
APPROACH TODAY BUT I DO HOPE
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM. AND I LOOK AT THEIR
AMENDMENTS AND CONSIDER TAKING
THEM- SO THAT I CAN SUPPORT IT
ON THE FLOOR AS WELL. ABSOLUTELY
I APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE WORKED WITH- THE
OPPOSITION WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO. I THINK THEIR MAIN
OPPOSITION AS WAS STATED TO YOU
PERSONALLY BUT I JUST DON'T LIKE
KERN LAW. THIS DOESN'T. YOUR
CHANGE CURRENT LAW IT'S JUST
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GONNA GET TO A PLACE.
WHERE YOU KNOW THEY'RE GONNA BE
SATISFIED BECAUSE OF THEIR
CONCERNS WITH CURRENT LAW. ABOUT
AGAIN THIS IS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT ITS ABOUT- INSURING THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE PREPARED I
COME FROM. A REGION THAT WAS THE
EPICENTER OF OUR YOU KNOW THE
LAST MAJOR EARTHQUAKE OF OUR
STATE AND IN- NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. AND SO CERTAINLY- WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT A WHAT WE- HAD TO GO
THROUGH THEN- INSURING THAT
WE'RE PREPARED IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. WE'LL TAKE THAT IS
YOUR CLOSEST BILLS. HELLO SIR.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
TO THE AUTHOR I'VE HAD A COUPLE
OF HOSPITALS CLOSE IN MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE ISSUES RELATED
TO WHAT YOU WANT TO ADDRESS. UP
I DIVIDE MY COMMUNITY CANNOT SEE
ANYMORE CLOSURES OF HOSPITALS
AND SO IN ONE OF THE DISTRICTS
THAT WAS HARDEST HIT BY COVERT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. THERE IS
INTENTIONALITY AND TRYING TO
WORK WITH THE HOSPITAL SOME OF
WHICH HAVE FROM MY OWN COMMUNITY
HAVE PUT IN THEIR LETTERS OF
OPPOSITION AND I WANT TO HELP
THEM GET TO A BETTER PLACE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO SO AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE'RE PROVIDING.
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE TO
COMMUNITIES OF NEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- ANY OTHER. BIGELOW I
THINK I WANNA CHIME AND A LOT OF
THOSE COMMENTS THAT OUR
COLLEAGUE OVER HERE JUST SPOKE
AND I LIKE THAT- THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HEARING THOSE
COMMENTS I APPRECIATE THAT THE
FACT THAT.YOU'VE TAKEN ON THIS
ISSUE I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU
WOULD TAKE ON A GREATER ISSUE
WHILE THERE IS. CURRENT LAW
ANYWHERE THE EPICENTER OF A LOT
OF TRAGIC. ACTIVITY THAT
OCCURRED. THERE IS. A GREATER
TRAGEDY THAT'S GOING TO OCCUR-
SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS TWELVE
HOSPITALS. AND ALL OF THEM ARE
GOING TO BE CLOSING. IN EVERYONE
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES SHORTLY.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MEET THE
DEMANDS. AND I THINK WE LOOK AT
ONE OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
SINGLE ON AND ONLY- I'M A
CENTERS. THEY'RE ABOUT TO LOSE
MORE THAN 70% OF THEIR BAD. IF
THE PUBLIC BECOMES MORE AWARE OF
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO LOSE AND
WE'RE AFTER WHAT WE JUST CAME
THROUGH. WITH THE TRAUMA OF
COVERT- WHERE WILL WE BE WITHOUT
THOSE HOSPITALS AND THOSE THAT.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T USE THEM. THE
B. JUST. SHELLS OF THE BUILDINGS
STANDING THERE. WE NEED TO AS AN
ENTIRE BODY STEP UP TO THE
REALITY OF THIS FIGURE OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO EITHER ON THE
RETROFITTING. OR HOW WE'RE GOING
TO ADDRESS ALLOWING THEM TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE IN BILLINGS M.
IN MY MOST MEASURES ARE SOUND
BUILDINGS IT MADE IT THROUGH
EVERY EARTHQUAKE. TO THIS POINT
. SO I APPLAUD YOU AND I HOPE
AND ENCOURAGE YOU. TO TAKE THIS
BIGGER ISSUE ON. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WE KNOW THAT YOU'LL
DO WHAT YOU SAID YOU WOULD DO-
THIS RIVAS AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ALL THIS BILL-
DEVELOPS AS IT MOVES FRWARD
IT'S OUT ON A BE REAL COOL. MR
FONG IF YOU WOULD. BE PREPARED
TO PRESENT FOR MR SANTIAGO ON A.
B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE AND
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE. THEY BOTH
ENJOYED TO PASS. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. ABOUT FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
ONE CREATES AN EDUCATION AVAIL
NOTICING REQUIREMENTS SET UP
POTENTIAL ADOPTERS OF DOGS AND
CATS KNOW HOW THEIR PETS SHOULD
BE TREATED THIS BILL HAS NO
ESTIMATE AS MEDICAL AS THE STATE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BUT- THANK YOU. I WILL TURN TO
THE- THE PUBLIC IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO LEND
SUPPORT. IN FAVOR OF EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY ONE. THE NON WILL TURN TO
THE- SEE NOW WILL TURN TO THE
PHONE LAW. OKAY PLEASE COME
FORWARD. I'M SORRY SUPPORT.
RACHEL GATES ORANGE OUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WE'LL
TURN OKAY THIS CALL FOR THIS IS
IN SUPPORT. FREEWATCH PLASTER
COUNTY AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE. LOVE DOGS
AND CATS WHO WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY PROTECT THEM. THANK
YOU. GO TO THE PHONE LINES
SUPPORT ON EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
WITH HER BACK TO BE A PUBLIC
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION. EIGHTEEN ANYONE. A
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF
THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS THE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SHELTERS IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL WE OPPOSE
IT ON POLICY AND PROMISE NOT ON
FISCAL I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE BUT READ THE ROOM I WILL
REMAIN OPPOSED. THANK YOU THANK
. THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION. TURN THE PHONE LINES
. OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
ONE. ALL RIGHT AND WE HAVE A
LINE ONE SIXTY FIVE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL. AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY SIX. WHEN
THE PATRICK OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MMHM. LINE Q. ZERO Q. MY NAME IS
NICOLE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE SB ONE EIGHT EIGHT. IT'S. ARE THERE ANY OTHERS ONLINE TO
OPPOSE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE
TERRORIST IT'LL BE ONE MOMENT
SURE I HAVE LEVEL COMMENT FROM
LINE ONE SIXTY ONE. HI MY NAME
IS NICHOLA SOCKET SORRY I'M A
LITTLE BIT LATE BUT- COLLEEN IN
SUPPORT. OF REPRESENTING SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION PROP
FONT OF THE BILL. AND OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE. ONE
EIGHTY NINE. BOB HELLO
OPPOSITION. AND LINE TWO ZERO
FOR YOUR LINES OPEN. I'M SORRY
THAT IT WAS IN IN Q. BUT I DO
APPROVE OF THIS BILL. LINE SIXTY
SEVEN. WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY
LINE ONE NINETY ONE YOUR LINES
OPEN. JENNIFER KORN AS OPPOSED.
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN AGAIN. TO ME IF YOU AMEND
THIS BILL I COULD APPROVE.
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE MOVE ON. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL AND MISTER CHAIR YES AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT OKAY WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. SEE
NOTE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL WITH VINCE FONG NOT
VOTING. OKAY WILL KNOW YOUR
PRESENTATION ON THE NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE OR MR SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH UNNECESSARY
GOOD MORNING- MISTER MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIGUEL
SANTIAGO ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE MOVE THE BILL WILL
ALLOW DOCUMENT AND NONCITIZENS
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR COUNTY BOARD
APPOINTED POSITIONS. THIS BILL
WILL HAVE MINOR ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
BUT THANK YOU THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION IS OUR SECOND. AND SECOND
BY MR JONES SAWYER. I WILL TURN
TO THE PUBLIC IS THERE ANY
COMMENT IN SUPPORT. ON NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE. MOST OF THE PHONE
LINES PHONE OPERATOR SUPPORT A
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND THERE ARE NO COMMENTS
IN THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR BACK
TO THE HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION.
THE NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE. THIRTY
NINE OWNER OPERATOR WILL NOW
ENTERTAIN OPPOSITION TO NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE. AND WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE ONE SIXTY SIX
. THUNDERCRACKER CONNIE I OPPOSE. IN LINE A ONE NINETY ONE.
JENNIFER CORTES A CLOSE. NINE
ONE FORTY SEVEN. FORTY SEVEN
YEAR LINES OPEN. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS LINDA FROM
PLASTER COUNTY A DISCONNECTED
MYSELF PLAN VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE.
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
ZERO PEOPLE ARE TOO OLD FOR. YES
THIS IS STEPHANIE SALINE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. IT'LL BE ONE
MORE MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT COMMENT
. IF. AND THAT NEXT COMIC COMES
FROM LINE WHICH. TO TWENTY TWO.
MY NAME IS RENEE ROMERO AND I
OPPOSE. AND OUR NEXT COMMENT
WILL BE COMING FROM LINE TO
SIXTEEN. HI LARRY I HAD A NICKEL
DIFFICULT EITHER- MY NAME'S ALEX
BACK IN FACT MY FIRM ACTUALLY
SUPPORTING I THANK THE COURT.
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE. AND THERE
ARE NO FURTHER FURTHER COMMENTS
IN THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU THE MOTION IS A DO PASS THE
ANY QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHTS IT'S
OUT ON A. B. ROLL CALL. MR LOW.
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO HAVE PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE
PROTECT EVERY DAY CALIFORNIANS
THE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THIS
CHAIR MEMBERS DENNIS CUSTOMER
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SPONSORS OF THE BILL
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. THEY KNOW OTHERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WILL TURN
TO THE PHONE OPERATOR WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT EIGHT IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I OPPOSE THIS YOU NEED TO TAKE
MY CALL I'M- NOT MAKING THAT
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
NO NARRATIVES BEYOND THAT. MR
HERE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU OKAY
WE WILL NOW TAKE OPPOSITION WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE TWO
PEOPLE WITH- IF YOU COULD
TESTIFY FROM THE- MICROPHONE
RIGHT YES THANK OU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS DENISE I'M CO FOUNDER
FREEDOM ANGELS AND PRESIDENT OF
SILICON COUNTY LIBERTY
COALITION. I'M ACTUALLY GOING TO
GIVE MY TIME TO DOCTOR WONG TWO
THOUSAND LEADING TIME- I THOUGHT
WE WERE GIVEN THE OKAY FOR THE
DOCTOR WANT TO TESTIFY HE'S A
BOARD CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN IN
OPPOSITION WITHIN HIS TIME YES.
YES I THAT THERE ARE TWO SEATS
NOT. TWENTY ONE YOU HAVE BEEN A
PRACTICING PHYSICIAN. PLASTER
COUNTY APPRECIATE A CHAIR TO
ALLOW ME TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU.
MY FEELING ABOUT THIS BILL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. OF THE SCIENCE
IS A VERY FLUID- PROCESS. THERE
IS NO ONE HAS ABSOLUTE TRUTH. TO
SCIENCE ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO MEDICINE. YEAH I HAVE TREATED
THOUSANDS PUBLICATION AND HAVE
NOW LOST ONE PATIENT. NBDL TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY F. A. FALL
CHIANA FAMOUSLY SAID WE DON'T
NEED TO WEAR MASKS AND THE NEXT
DAY HE SAID WE NEED TO WEAR
MASKS AS YOU CAN SEE THE
RECOGNITION RECOMMENDATION
CHANGES WITH A VACCINE. AT ONE
POINT IN THE BEGINNING A
VACCINE- IMPLEMENTATIONS WAY HER
FROM THE HILL CDC AND FISER CEO
SAYS THE VACCINE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE THERE'S NO DEATH THE
FIRST FOUR MONTHS AND NOW THAT
WITH T. RELEASE ALL THE
INFORMATION FROM FISER FRIEDMAN
FOR MISSION THAT WE FIND OUT
THERE'S MANY MANY SIDE EFFECTS
AND INJURY AND DEATH OF SOCIALLY
WITH THE FAXING SO THIS IS A
FLUID PROCESS WE NEED TO ALLOW
SCIENCE TO. PROGRESS AND IMPROVE
OUR ALBERTEINSTEIN. THIS THE
BILL SCIENCE THE THIS SIZE SO WE
KNOW OFF. IN IN THE HISTORY OF
MAN. WITH HIS OF RELATIVITY
RELATIVITY HE HAS NEVER WON
SAID. I ONLY TRUTH ANYONE KNOW
IF YOU WERE TO SPREAD
MISINFORMATION I'M GOING TO
CANCEL YOU. SO THAT'S NOT HALL
SCIENCE AND THAT'S NOT ALL
MEDICINE WORK. AND ASSEMBLY
MENLO AND I HOPE THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND. THAT WITH THIS BILL
IF IT'S PASS THEN EVERYTHING
THAT WE HAVE. TRANSPIRED IN THE
PAST TWO YEARS IN THE BEGINNING
OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY WITH OLD
INFORMATION COMING OUT ABOUT
COBIT. IT'S NOT ACCURATE NOW SO
ALL THIS DECISION THAT SUPPORT
THE MEASURE IN VIRGINIA TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. THEY WILL ALL
BE CANCEL AND THEY'LL ALL BE
DISCIPLINED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND THAT'S NOT RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. I WILL
TAKE- NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL. IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU TO THE
CELLULAR CO FOUNDER FREEDOM
ANGELS IN OPPOSITION OF THE
SPELL. MY NAME IS MIKE. I AM OF
THE ORGANIZATION WHO OWNS YOUR
BODY DOES WHO OWN YOUR BODY IF
YOU OWN YOUR SORRY THIS NAY
AMERICANIZATION AN ORGANIZATION
ANALIZAR ORGANIZATION. WE NEED.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
BAKER. WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT SPEAKER. SIR YOUR TIME
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE OUT OF
ORDER. YOU KNOW THE RULES YOU
WILL BE EXPORTED OUT IF YOU'RE
NOT FOLLOWING THEM. ZERO I
REPRESENT WE THE PEOPLE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS DR TERESA CON I'M A
BOARD CERTIFIED PSYCHIATRIST NO
BEHALF OF MY PATIENCE MY FUTURE
PATIENTS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL SCIENCE IS NOT SETTLED.
SHRIYA LUNCH. SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF JAMES TO RALLY RUNNING FOR US
SENATE. AND ALSO SPEAKING FOR
LABORATORY PROFESSIONALS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. AB TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT. YOU GUYS WAY CANNOT
INFRINGE. NAME ORGANIZATION THAT
IS IT THE POSITION ON THE BILL
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE NEXT SPEAKER
PLEASE THANK YOU. RACHEL
IVERMECTIN GATES ORANGE COUNTY
PRESCHOOL TEACHER MOTHER I
STRONGLY PPOSE THIS BILL FOR
OBVIOUS REASONS TO- NINE EIGHT.
PLEASE GILES WITH TODAY WAS
RELEASED ON YOUTUBE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT. A SCENE. NO OTHERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO. THANK THEIR
POSITION ON THIS BILL WILL MOVE
TO THE IN THE HEARING ROOM WILL
MOVE TO ONLINE TO THE PHONE
OPERATOR. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO. NAME
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION OF NON
SUPPORT. FOR TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT
IF YOU ARE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME. LINE
TWO ZERO. NINE NINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ALLISON SERRANO PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA BEING KEEPERS I AM IN
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT THANK YOU. TWO FOUR. STILL
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF STONES
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION. ONE
THREE EIGHT. KATHLEEN THOMAS
KERN COUNTY OPPOSE. TWO TWO
EIGHT. THE HEARING L. SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AYE OPPOSED AB TWO
ZERO NINE EIGHT. TWO THREE ZERO.
MY NAME IS MARYLAND- ARE YOU
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL AND
GREATLY SUPPORT THANK YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU UNDER BUT. THANKS
BAKER PRESIDENT OF THE TRI
VALLEY REPUBLICANS ALAMEDA
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
ORWELLIAN TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT.
TWO FOUR ZERO. HI MY NAME IS
JESSICA CABRERA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PROTECTION OF THE
EDUCATION RIGHT TO KIDS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT. FRANCE COUNTY AT
RIVERSIDE AMBASSADOR BLACK BAND
I OPPOSE THE BILL. ONE SEVEN
FIVE. ONE SEVEN FIVE. ONE SEVEN
FIVE IF YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO IF I
HAD. HI MY NAME IS BENEFIT
CENTER SAM FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE AB TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT. ONE FIFTY FOUR.
GABRIELLE FOUNDER AND THAT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AMERICANS
AGAINST COMMUNISM WE OPPOSE.
CHIU FORTY FIVE. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNIFER COLLINS FINAL
AND I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION OF
TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT THE DOCTORS
ALONE. THIRTY SEVEN. THIRTY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS THE COOPER
THOUGHT ARE STRONGER BOTH WHO
THEIR OWN EIGHT AS THE PARA IT
ALWAYS GETS EXPECTING OPINION.
TO SIX. HI AS GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS VERONICA AND I'M CALLING
TO OPPOSE AB TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT
THANK YOU. TWO TWO NINE. ARADIA
VOLUNTEER WITH CALIFORNIA
FREEDOM KEEPERS IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT. TWO ZERO
FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS THE UNDER
BROWN FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND
I OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU. FIFTY THREE. OKAY MY
NAME A CHARACTER IN THE NIGHT
ALAMEDA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL DEFINES IS NOT SETTLED
THANK YOU ONE SEVENTY SIX. HELLO
MY NAME IS HEATHER HUMANISM FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK'S DISTRICT
AND I'M ASKING YOU TO PLEASE THE
POLITICAL. ONE SIXTY FIVE. MY
NAME IS JOBS. SACRAMENTO I
OPPOSE. TWO ZERO THREE. HI MY
NAME IS MARK NEWMAN I HAVE A
FARM ON THE PHARMACIST THAT'S MY
BACKGROUND I'M CALLING ORANGE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. EIGHTY EIGHT. YES MY
NAME IS MONIQUE REPRESENTING
WITH YOUR PARENTS FOR CHOICE AND
STRONG OPPOSITION OF TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT. TWO THIRTY NINE. TWO
THREE NINE. YES IN THE MARINO I
WITH LATINA MOTHERS AND
DAUGHTERS HI WE OPPOSE IT AND
CONSTITUTIONAL BILL. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY. HI MY NAME IS LINDA
BUCHNER FROM PLASTER COUNTY
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU DR MICHAEL
ONE I STRONGLY WE'RE GOING TO
SELL THANK. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING OPEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. CHIU FORTY ONE
. ON A DEFENSIVE BONTA MODERATE
DAMAGE OPPOSE A. B. THERE ARE
NORMAL. TWENTY TWO. MY NAME IS
RENEE ROMERO THE CALL FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. SIXTY NINE. SIXTY NINE
POINT DR ED. HI MY NAME IS GERRY
MILLER I'M A CHILD ADVOCATE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT THANK YOU. IN
NINETEEN. TWO HUNDRED. ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO FORTY FOUR.
ANDREW STERN STRONGLY OPPOSE.
YOU TWENTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT ON
ITS LACK OF MERIT. TWO THIRTY.
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SIX HI MY
NAME IS CINDY BROUGHT HAS I AM A
NURSE AND MOTHER OF TWO AND A
MEMBER OF THE GROUP OF VALLEY
STAND FOR FREEDOM I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. TWO FORTY
EIGHT. ON ANOTHER NOTE FROM
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. FIFTY HI MY NAME IS
OLENA BRASILIA I AM A MOTHER OF
TWO AND A SOCIAL WORKER I LIVE
IN MONROVIA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. TWO
ZERO FOUR. YES MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE THRILLA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL WITHOUT
HYDROCHLORIC WHEN MY DAUGHTER
DI<c.cyan> FORTY TWO. WHEN THE STATIC</c>
FROM STOCKTON A MOTHER OF TWO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
. ONE NINETY FIVE. YES HELLO THE
CARRIER AND ALL FROM FREES SIDE
AND BISHOP CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. TWO
THIRTY TWO. KATHY WHITE MEN FROM
ONE WINTER CALIFORNIA I AM A
MEMBER OF SAVE OUR CINEMA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE
EIGHTY NINE. THE BULLDOGS FROM
GRANADA HILLS A MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL
EIGHTEEN I OPPOSE THIS INSANITY
. ONE NINETY SIX HER OR IN
HINCKLEY HERE LET'S GET
ORGANIZED FOLKS GO TO REBUILD
CALIFORNIA .COM I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. TWO ZERO TWO. TWO HUNDRED
TWO. TWO ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SEVENTY FOUR. SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WINE SEVEN
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE ZERO
NINE. IT IS RATES OKAY CAN'T
WITH NO WITH USD FOR FREEDOM WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL. TWO
FOUR SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MELISSA CANNON FROM BRENTWOOD
CALIFORNIA OTHER OF FOUR AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. TWO ONE TWO.
SAN DIEGO R. N. AYE OPPOSED YOUR
MEDICAL TYRANNY. ONE ZERO FOUR.
AND I'M GOOD FOR. HELLO THAT B.
YES. SORRY I DIDN'T GET THE
NUMBER WHEN IT CAME MY NAME IS
AMBER BLADEN- I'M IN A NUMBER OF
PARENTS VOICE FOR CHOICE OF
MARIPOSA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
WE OPPOSE AB TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT
THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN TWO. ONE
SEVENTY TWO. CAN YOU GREEN THAT
ARE THE KING OF KINGS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. TWO THIRTEEN.
YES HI SALLY MASLEN LOS ANGELES
STRONGLY OPPOSES MEDICAL TYRANNY
. ONE SIXTY SIX. THE MATTER
STRONGLY OPPOSE. ZERO NINE
EIGHT. FIVE ONE. ONE TWO NINE HE
- YES CANNISTRARO RESIDENT OF
AND WEBER SORRY COUNTY TIME
ABOUT THEIR PRODUCTIVITY THE
LARGEST MARKET A MOVE OUT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN AMERICA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE TWO ZERO
NINETY. ONE NINE ONE. JENNIFER
CORNER STRONGLY OPPOSED. TWO
FIVE THREE. HI MY NAME IS LAURA
FRAZIER I'M A RESIDENT OF SANTA
CLARITA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
TWENTY NINETY. TWO THREE THREE.
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY THREE. TWO
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO RYAN ONE
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. I OPPOSE L.
NINE ONE NINE NINE. HELLO
LISABETH KENNY FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA THE BAND HAMMERLOCK
IMAMS AGAINST OVER REACHING AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NINE TWO FIVE NINE. HI LEVINE
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
FURNITURE HOME YOU FOR FREEDOM
YEAH THAT SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
AND. AND CALIFORNIA FREEDOM KEEP
BIRDS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
EIGHT ZERO NINETEEN. NINE ONE
NINE TWO. HI AMBER GALLAGHER.
CONVENTION HAVING CALIFORNIA
HEARING OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ZERO NINE EIGHT. TWO
SEVEN EIGHT. WE GREEDO PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER AND MOTHER OF TWO
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE THEMSELVES STRONGLY. TWO
EIGHT FIVE. ON MY FINAL NIGHT OF
CODES. TWO EIGHT EIGHT. ON THE
LINE EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU CAN SHOW THEM ON
BEHALF OF HER PROTECT ON THE
RIGHT HE WAS OPPOSE THANK YOU.
ONE SEVEN FIVE. ONE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE. NINE TWO SIX THREE
. MY NAME IS CHRISTINA MCKINNEY
I AM A NURSE IN RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES AND I
OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SEVENTY FOUR.
HI MY NAME IS FULLY SALTMAN I'M
AN ATTORNEY FROM ORANGE COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE- THIS BILL THIS
IS COMMUNISM PEOPLE YOU NEED TO
. NINE TWO NINE EIGHT. HI MY
NAME IS CARA ADAMS I'M A NURSE I
AM FROM ALL HONESTY PARENTS
AGAINST MANDATE AND STAND UP ON
KARAMANA CLAIRE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT.
ONE SIX FIVE. MY NAME IS JASMINE
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE
EACH TWO NINE SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ELENA AND I
AM A MEMBER OF NETWORKING COUNTY
LIBERTY COALITION AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THREE ZERO THREE.
MORE A CALL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR GOOD GOVERNANCE
AND OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT. THREE ZERO FOUR.
MY NAME IS ALYSSA SONORA OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND LOS ANGELES
EDUCATORS AND PARENTS UNITED AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
AGAINST OUR DOCTORS AB TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU. THREE
ZERO ONE. THREE HUNDRED ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE ZERO ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE FIVE. HI
MY NAME IS JACOB LAWRENCE I'M A
CERTIFIED HEMODIALYSIS
TECHNICIAN FROM CHRONIC
CALIFORNIA ALSO PART OF THE
CRIMINAL CODE UNIFIED- DISTRICT
PARENTS FOR CHOICE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT I'M NOT A DOCTOR
NEITHER YOU. SEVEN SIX. TWELVE
NINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS SALIM FROM-
PLAN REPRESENTING A BLUEPRINT
FOR CHANGE AND FREEDOM AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
OCTOBER. GOOD MORNING I'M- WELL
I AM A PHYSICIAN SO I GUESS I
CAN TALK BASED OFF OF WHAT ONE
OF THOSE CALLERS SAID. I'M I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- YOU KNOW AS A BOARD
CERTIFIED OBGYN. WE KNOW THAT WE
TAKE AN OATH TO DO NO HARM. AND
THIS BILL MAKE SURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS. I REALLY HOPE THAT
EVERYONE WHO SUPPORTS AND
OPPOSES READ SPELLS AND
UNDERSTANDS WHAT IT SAYS. ON
BECAUSE IT SPEAKS OUT VERY
CLEARLY WHAT IT MEANS TO
DISSEMINATE- AND WHAT
DISINFORMATION AS- WHICH MEANS
MISINFORMATION THAT THE
LICENSEE. DELIBERATELY
DISSEMINATED WITH MALICIOUS
INTENT OR INTENT TO MISLEAD. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT SCIENCE
FLUCTUATES BUT WHEN YOU GO IN
THERE DELIBERATELY. PLANNING TO
CAUSE HARM THAT IS A PROBLEM. IT
ALSO SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT
PRIOR TO BRINGING A DISCIPLINARY
ACTION AGAINST THE LICENSEE
UNDER THIS SECTION THE BOARD
SHALL CONSIDER BOTH WHETHER THE
LICENSEE DEPARTED FROM THE
APPLICABLES STANDARD OF CARE AND
WHETHER THE MISINFORMATION OR
DISINFORMATION RESULTED IN HARM
TO A PATIENT. WE SHOULD NOT BE
OUT PURPOSELY HARMING OUR
PATIENTS. SO THANK YOU I STAND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS THE- AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBSTETRICIAN GYNECOLOGISTS
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AND MANY OTHER
PHYSICIAN GROUPS. THAT SUPPORT
THIS ODD TO PROTECT OUR PATIENTS
AND ALSO OUR PROFESSION THANK
YOU. MR LOH DOCTOR RIVERS GIVEN
YOU'RE PRETTY STRONG CLOSE BUT
THE FLOOR IS YOURS IF YOU'D LIKE
TO. CLOSE ON BEHALF YOUR BILL. I
WAS GOOD TO HAVE A DOCTOR IN THE
HOUSE AND I'LL LEAVE THAT AS MY
CLOTHES AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE I. CONSIDERATION IN
PROTECTING. ALL CALIFORNIA. IS
OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL. DR KIRK. OKAY DR KIRK I'M STE DR WORK
I'M SO SORRY I DIDN'T SEE- THE
CARD IN THE- OKAY. REGARDING
YOUR PRESENT IN AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE INTEREST TO PASS
YES I AM. THANK YOU. EIGHT YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS A
BILL THAT AVAIL HELPS WORKING
PARENTS AND KIDS BY OFFERING
MORE FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN. YEAH
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY OR TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE. THEN I WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES PHONE OPERATORS
SUPPORT NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO. AND
TWO SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI MY NAME IS WRONGLY OPPOSED
THE BILL. WHEN I THINK YOU AT
THIS TIME. TWO ZERO TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO ZERO TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AFTER THIS I'M NOT ONE
OF BILL. ONE SEVEN THREE. THANK
YOU THREE THREE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD- THIS BILL PLEASE STOP
THIS. AND ALIGN ONE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JASMINE SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
ONE EIGHT NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE BALL LOG WITHOUT A HOST
OPPOSITION. FIND TWO ZERO FOUR.
THIS IS STEPHANIE SALE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THREE ONE ONE.
THREE ONE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT AWAY HELLO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL SORRY ABOUT THAT. FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS THE HEARING JOHN AYE
OPPOSED AB ONE NINE SEVEN THREE
. ONE SIX SIX. THREE PATRICK
COUNTY I OPPOSE. THREE THREE
FIVE. THE HOLIDAY AND I OPPOSE.
THREE THREE SEVEN. THREE THREE
SEVEN. ONE SEVEN NINE. ONE SEVEN
NINE. ZERO HI THIS IS LINDA FROM
PLASTER COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. EIGHT ONE
EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT WORKED. MISTER
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE THREE THREE NINE. ONE THREE
THREE NINE. NINE THREE THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE THREE NINE YEAR OPEN. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU RETURN TO THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THIS MCCARTY
DID YOU WANT TO CLOSE YOUR GOOD
OF THIS BILL IS OUT ON THE B.
ROLL CALL. THANK YOU. DR QUIRK
WE'RE SURE. YOU'RE PRESENTING AB
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR AND TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. THEY BOTH
ENJOYED TO PASS. I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION AND A SECOND. THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS OFTEN. EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR
YES DESPITE THE LEGAL STATUS OF
CANNABIS FOR MEDICAL AND
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES. OR NEAR.
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA STILL
FACE DISCRIMINATION BEST BASED
UPON POSITIVE. ARE THC TESTS IN
THE SURVEY OF SIX HUNDRED
PATIENTS EIGHTEEN AND A HALF
PERCENT OF RESPONDENTS.
REPORTING BEING DENIED
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS. DUE TO
THE USE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT MEDICAL
CANNABIS USE CAN REDUCE OPIOID
TREATMENT DOSE. AND OUR ABUSE
AND RESULT IN IMPUTE IMPROVED
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR PATIENTS. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR WOULD
PROHIBIT PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS
TWENTY NINE TREATMENT OR
MEDICATION TO A PATIENT BASED
SOLELY. ON THE POSITIVE THC
TEST. I THE BILL MAINTAINS
MEDICAL DISCRETION BY SIMPLY
EVALUATION VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CMA HELP US WORK THIS OUT THE
MAINTAINED THE RIGHT OF A
POSITION TO- THANK OF HIS
PATIENT. AS A INDIVIDUAL PERSON.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ON THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION FROM L. ACROSS YOUR
MONEY R IN DESIRABLE
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK YOU DR
COWORKER WILL TAKE ANY COMMENTS
OF SUPPORT A NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR
FROM THE COMMITTEE OR FROM THE
GOVERNOR. H. I. RIMAC TO GATES
ORANGE COUNTY A SUPPORT NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU. I SEE NO
OTHERS IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
COMMON IN SUPPORT OF PHONE
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW TAKE
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR ONLINE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEY'RE ALL AT
THIS TIME. LINE TWO ZERO TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
NICOLE I'M NOT FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
BILL ONE NINE FIVE OR- THIRTY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS THE COOPER
STARTED I'M GONNA SUPPORT OF
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR. SIXTEEN HI
MY NAME IS ALLEY FACT THAT
APARTMENT AND I. ONE FOUR NINE.
HELLO JACKIE COULD ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. FIFTY THREE. TERRIBLY
UNITE ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THEM. TWO FOUR
FIVE. TWO FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS JENNIFER
COLLINS WANNA TO PORT THIS BILL
. THREE THREE SIX. HELLO MY NAME
IS HEATHER HUMANISM FROM CORK'S
DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ONE EIGHT NINE.
WALGREN NODDED HILLS IN SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WILL
NOW TAKE OPPOSITION IN THE ROOMS
THE NON ONLINE PHONE OPERATOR
WILL NOW ENTERTAIN OPPOSITION TO
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR. ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEY'RE
ALL AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THREE FOUR ZERO THREE
FOUR ZERO. THREE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BERMAN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. MR HERE THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE CITY NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YOUR BILL
. HELLO SIR. YES MISTER JONES
SAWYER. UP MR QUIRK AS ONE OF
THE- FOUNDING FATHERS OF LEGAL
CANNABIS IN CALIFORNIA WHEN IT
THANK YOU FOR FURTHER HELPING
INTEGRATE THIS- LEGAL USE OF
CANNABIS IN CALIFORNIA- WE NEED
TO DO MORE MORE LEGISLATION LIKE
THIS OF BECOMES- NOT NECESSARILY
NORMALIZE BUT WE MAKE SURE THAT
IS DONE THE RIGHT WAY. AND SO
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT THE BILL
LIKE THIS THANK YOU AND AGAIN I
WANNA. THANK THE CMA FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS FAILED TO MAKE
SURE WE WOULD GET IT RIGHT. BILL
IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU
THANK. ARE YOU 1% TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN YEP. I'M CHAU THANK
YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. WOULD ALLOW
THE SALE AND DISTRIBUTION OF
COSMETICS DETERGENTS AND CERTAIN
CLEANING PRODUCTS. THAT ARE
APPROVED FOR SALE IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION OF WHICH DO NOT
INTENTIONALLY ADDED
MICROPLASTICS OF THE IDEA
EUROPEAN UNION SPENT FIVE YEARS
. UP WITH THAT PROPONENTS AND
OPPONENTS OF USING MICROPLASTICS
IN COSMETICS AND DETERGENTS AND
HAS COME UP WITH A- A SET OF
COMPROMISE- NOT REGULATIONS THAT
WOULD KEEP THIS PLASTIC OUT OF
OUR SEWER SYSTEMS. RIGHT NOW WE
BELIEVE THAT THE SEWER SYSTEMS
THAT ALL OF THIS PLASTIC ENDS UP
IN THE BIOSOLIDS WHICH WE THEN
DISTRIBUTE ON THE R. WHICH WE
THEN DISTRIBUTE ON FARMLAND AND
WE'RE TRYING TO DO MORE AND MORE
OF THAT. WE DO NOT WANT TO HAVE
MICROPLASTICS AND OUR FOOD OR IN
THE STREAMS OF WATERS THAT COME
OFF FROM THERE. WITH ME TODAY IS
NICOLE CURATE KOREAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
THROUGH. THIS IS HER RIGHT NOW
SHE WILL BE HERE TO MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT AND THEN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS ON THE
GLOBAL PERVASIVENESS OF
MICROPLASTICS HAS HAD
DEVASTATING EFFECTS ON THE
PLASTIC HAS CONTAMINATED EVERY
BIOME AND CONTINENT ON THE
PLANET INCLUDING ANTARCTICA AND
MICROPLASTICS ARE SO PERVASIVE
THEY HAVE BEEN FOUND IN WATER
SOIL AND EVEN AIR STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT OVER A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SPECIES INCLUDING HUMANS
INGEST MICROPLASTICS. IN
ADDITION TO NUMEROUS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WILDLIFE
IMPACTS CONTINUED EXPOSURE TO
MICROPLASTICS YOUR BREATHING
DRINKING AND EATING CAN HAVE
WORRISOME LONG TERM IMPACTS TO
HUMAN HEALTH STUDIES HAVE
IDENTIFIED MICROPLASTIC
POLLUTION IN HUMAN PLACENTA
BLOOD STREAMS AND LUNGS RESEARCH
HAS ALSO FOUND THAT
MICROPLASTICS CAN REACH
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTING CHEMICALS
CAN DAMAGE HUMAN CELLS.
CALIFORNIA HAS PREVIOUSLY TAKEN
ACTION TO REDUCE MICROPLASTIC
POLLUTION INCLUDING AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND PASSED
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHICH
BANNED THE SALE OF RINSE OFF
PRODUCTS CONTAINING MICROBEADS.
SHORTLY AFTER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ALSO PASSED
SIMILAR FEDERAL LEGISLATION.
HOWEVER MICROPLASTICS ARE STILL
PERVASIVE IN MANY OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT WE USE EVERY
SINGLE DAY. THIS BILL TAKES AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS REDUCING
UNNECESSARY MICROPLASTIC
POLLUTION MAKES PRODUCTS SAFER
FOR CALIFORNIANS CONSUMER HEALTH
OR WILDLIFE AND ENVIRONMENT WITH
LITTLE COST IMPLICATION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU I WILL NOW TAKE-
ANY COMMENTS OF SUPPORT HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. RETOOK ITS
ORANGE COUNTY PRESCHOOL TEACHER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I SEE NO
OTHER WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES PHONE OPERATOR WILL TAKE
SUPPORT ON TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEY'RE ALL AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE FOUR SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY YES. YESI
JUST WANTED TO STATE MY
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT AND AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. NINE THREE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS NICOLE.
AND I. THREE FIFTEEN. LAURA
ROSENBERGER HIGHER SHOULD FRESNO
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. FIFTY
THREE. MY NAME IS CARA WITH
UNITE ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
SUPPORT THE L. TWO NINETEEN. TWO
ONE NINE. TWO HUNDRED NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO TWO ZERO.
HI MY NAME IS LINDA WITH DOCTOR
COUNTY CALIFORNIA I AM STRONG IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THAT
THERE'S MANY MANY MANY
CONTAMINANTS IN EVERY PRODUCT
THAT WE USE THANK YOU TO THE
STATE NAME ORDER. ON YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK. TWO
FOUR FIVE. YES MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CONSOLE AND I'M FROM-
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THREE THREE SIX.
ORDER ME YES HI MY NAME IS
SEVENTY MINUTES FROM FROM THE
FAMILY MEMBERS QWIKSTER STRICT
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
. ONE FOUR NINE. HELLO JACKIE
CODA PRESIDENT TRY VALLEY
REPUBLICANS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. TWO ZERO
FOUR. YES JAPANESE LEYVA AND I
DO SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT WE NEED
TO STOP BUYING PLASTIC. TWO TWO
ZERO. THREE THREE FIVE. THE
HOLIDAY AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. ONE NINE ONE SIX
SIX. ONE SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I FELT. THANK YOU ARE. MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU WILL
TURN TO THE HEARING ROOM FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE TO WITNESSES
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION MANDY LEE.
AND IN THE COLD WHEN THE ONUS.
YES SHARE- COMMITTEE YES. A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS-
MAYBE ME ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
WE ARE CLOSE TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WE APPRECIATE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR- BUT THE ASSERTION THAT
THIS THE LINE WITH THE E. U. S.
NOT- WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE YET-
THIS BILL AGGRESSIVE MARKET
BASKET OF MEDICS INCLUDING
CLEANING PRODUCTS AND IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT THE PRODUCT
CATEGORIES PRESCRIBED IN THE
FALL REPRESENTS ZERO POINT 2% OF
THE PROBLEM WHEN IT COMES TO
MICROPLASTICS ACCORDING TO A
RECENT STUDY CONDUCTED IN THE
VEHICLE. FURTHERMORE THIS BILL
WOULD SERVE A DEFECTIVE BAN ON
PRODUCTS BY BANNING NON PLASTIC
POLYMERS WHICH MAKE UP PRODUCTS
WATERPROOF LASTING FEDERAL FOR
WHICH THERE ARE NO VIABLE
ALTERNATIVESWHICH CAN LEAD TO
THE FISCAL IMPACT ON THE STATE
SHOULD STILL MOVE FORWARD AS IN
IT WILL BAN COUNTLESS PRODUCTS
THAT CONSUMERS RELY ON TODAY A
RESULT IN LOSS JOBS LOST INCOME
TAX REVENUE AND LA SALLE TAX
OBVIOUSLY URGENT. ABOUT SH SH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF
GOOD MORNING A CALL OUT OF A
BEHALF OF HOUSEHOLD COMMERCIAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE BREAK AND
CREATORS A THIRTY ALL WITHIN A
NOT THE MAN TO PAY I TWENTY
EIGHTY. OUT DO A THE FROM THE
ALL TWELVE AT THE WITH THE AND
THE FORWARD TO WORKING TOWARD
THAT GOAL HOWEVER BASED ON THE
CURRENT TAX IN ABOUT- DETAIL
QUICKLY THE FISCAL IMPACT OF THE
MENU AT THE AS THAT WOULD BE.
FOR EXAMPLE MANY COMPANY ARE IN
FACT TENS MILLIONS OF TO BEGIN
IN AND ABOUT FRAGRANCE AND
CATHOLIC THAT FIT THE
BIODEGRADABLE STANDARDS
ESTABLISHED IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION SHOULD THE BILL PASS
WITHOUT THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT
INVESTMENT WOULD BE LOCKED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE GREATER
THAN CATHOLIC ALSO ALLOWED FOR
THE USE OF 30% LACK FRAGRANCE
ANY BAND WOULD REQUIRE COMPANIES
NEED TO INVEST HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
PURCHASING ADDITIONAL FRAGRANCE
THAT IN ORDER TO DELIVER THE
SAME AMOUNT OF SPENT AT THE
DELIVERED WITH ENCAPSULATED.
MEMBERS WOULD ALSO NAY TO INVITE
ME TO FACTORS THAT ALTERNATE TO
ADJUST- THEIR MANUFACTURE.
INPUTS Q. CHANGE OVER TECH- THAT
IS NO LONGER RELATED TO AND THEN
PURCHASE NEW IT. AND LASTLY PER
PRODUCT WOULD BE A- TO BE READ
U. BAND CHRIS IN TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WHAT.
IN YOUR- HIGHLIGHTING A BLOCK
THAT BE YOU NEED TO MENTIONED
THE STATE WELL I FOR THESE
REASONS WE STIL A- UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
PHONE OPERATOR WILL ANY OTHER.
COM ARE ON OPPOSITION THIS WOULD
BE NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION
OF OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NINE THREE FOUR ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THREE ONE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAR ZERO
BANNER REPRESENTING THE UNION
SAG AFTRA ACTOR'S UNION WE.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU- TO THE COMMITTEE
THE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- DR
CORRECT WOULD ELECTRICALS OUT
CERTAINLY SO. THE INTENTION AND
THE FINAL RESULT OF THIS BILL
WILL BE IF YOU COULD SELL IT IN
THE E. U. YOU CAN SELL IT HERE.
IF THEY CAN MANUFACTURE THIS
THESE PRODUCTS IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION THAT CAN MANAGE.
MANUFACTURING THEM HERE- WITH
REGARD TO- WE WILL MAKE SURE
THAT ARE BOUGHT THAT ONE. WE
HAVE THE RIGHT SET OF
AMENDMENTS. ARE THERE ARE THERE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES THINGS
LIKE THE E. U. DEFINING
MICROPLASTICS ONE WAY CALIFORNIA
ANOTHER SO IT'S DIFFICULT TO.
LINE EVERYTHING UP WE WILL BE
TAKING THE MEASUREMENTS ON THE
FLOOR AND- FURTHER AMENDMENTS AS
WE GO THROUGH THE SENATE. GET
EVERYTHING LINED UP BUT IT'S A
GREAT. IT'S  TECHNICAL
CHALLENGE AND- WE'LL MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THAT TECHNICAL
CHALLENGE DON AND I HAVE- MY
FORMER- CCS T. SCIENCE FELLOW
WORKING ON THIS SO I KNOW IT'LL
GET DONE RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU WE HAVE ALL THE
CONFIDENCE IN THE WORLD UNTIL
WE'RE COULD CONTINUE TO WORK IT
AND BE COOPERATIVE ON THAT.
DONNA B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR STONE. AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SEVEN. ENJOYS A DO
PASS ERROR MOTION. THEN MOVED
AND SECONDED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS BILL. REMOVES
PEOPLE FROM DEATH ROW WHO ARE
INCOMPETENCE. AND CANNOT BE
EXECUTED UNDER THE STATE'S
CONSTITUTION SO THE FACT THAT
THEY LANGUAGE THERE IS EXPENSIVE
AND IS HIGHLY INAPPROPRIATE FOR
SETTING UP A PROCESS HERE TO
REMOVE PEOPLE FROM DEATH ROW IN
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE. I SHOULD BE
MINOR ABSORBER WAS HERE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT TO ASK THE RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL TURN TO ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT
SAYING NINE PHONE OPERATOR.
SUPPORT ON TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN. WHY NUMBER THREE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'VE MANY
FISCALLY BARNARD AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
WITH HER TO THE HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION. SEE NON PHONE OFFERS
PHONE OPERATOR OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN. AND
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU JACK THANK YOU
ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THEY NONE
THE BILL IS OUT ON THE B. ROLL
CALL THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU. DR
WEBER. YOU HAVE- TO BILLS
SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO AND SIXTEEN
THIRTY SIX BOTH ENJOYED THE PAST
. AND YOU'RE GONNA TAKE UP
SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO FIRST. NINETY
SIX SEVENTY TWO FIRST IF YOU
COULD OKAY. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY TO THE RESTROOM
ACCESS ACT WOULD PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALS WITH CERTAIN MEDICAL
CONDITIONS MOVE THE BILL.
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO EMPLOYEE
RESTROOM WHERE THERE IS NOT A
PUBLIC RESTROOM AVAILABLE AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO INSURERS
ACCESS TO RESTROOM FOR CUSTOMERS%
WHO PRESENT WITH A CERTIFIED
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
<c.blue>OCUMENT SIGNED BY MEDICAL</c>
PROFESSION ATTESTING THAT THE
CUSTOMER USES AN OSTOMY DEVICE
HAS CROHN'S DISEASE ULCERATIVE
COLITIS OR ANOTHER INFLAMMATORY
BOWEL DISEASE. OR MEDICAL
CONDITION REQUIRING ACCESS TO A
TOILET FACILITY IMMEDIATELY THE
CROHN'S AND COLITIS FOUNDATION
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS DETAILED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE COST
IS MINOR AND OBSERVABLE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON AB SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO. THANK
YOU RETURN TO THOSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM FOR SUPPORT. AND
THEN WE MOVED TO PHONE LINE
PHONE OPERATOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
- TOGETHER SUPPORT FOR SIXTEEN
THIRTY TWO A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY
TWO. WE DO HAVE A COMMENT FROM
LINE. THREE FORTY SIX THREE
FORTY SECURE LINES OPEN. I
SUPPORT THIS FILMING IN CECILIA
BARNARD THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU
HELLO TO LINE NUMBER. THREE
FIFTY FIVE. IT'S ALL PART OF LOS
ANGELES CAN SUPPORT PARTICULARLY
FOR DAUGHTER ACTUALLY TALKS
BURKE. AND THEN TWENTY I'M SORRY
TO TWENTY. I WHEN THE BUCKNER
FROM PLASTIC COUNTY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. SURE THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE. A PHONE
OPERATOR WILL TAKE OPPOSITION TO
SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO. AND THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE IF
WE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SEEINGNO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OF THIS BILL IS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU. SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX I
AM HERE TO PRESERVE ALSO PRESENT
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX THE
PATIENT PROTECTION ACT A BILL TO
MAINTAIN CONFIDENCE IN THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION BY ENSURING
PHYSICIANS CONVICTED OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT AGAINST A PATIENT
AUTOMATICALLY HAVE THEIR LICENSE
REVOKED AND CANNOT ACQUIRE OR
HAVE IT REINSTATED THE BILL HAS
MINOR AND ABSORB ALL COSTS TO
THE- M. NBC N. O. N. B. C. AND
TO SPEAK I SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX I HAVE DENNIS
CUEVAS ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
WELCOME VISITOR DEMOCRATS WERE
OUT WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THE BILL HAS A MOTION
ON IT'S A DO PASSES ARE SECOND.
AND SECONDED ANYONE IN THE
HEARING REMEMBER LIKE TO LEND
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR KAREN LANG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THEY KNOW
OTHER WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES SUPPORT ON A. B. SIXTEEN
THIRTY SIX. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THE BILL
IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. THANK YOU. DR QUIRK IF YOU WOULD BE KIND
ENOUGH TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF.
REMEMBER GIPSON A. B. NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN. THIS ENJOYS A DO
PASS. THE GOAL OF AB NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN IS TO ADDRESS HOW
CAMPUS POLICE RESPOND RESPOND TO
CALLS ON CAMPUS THE BILL
REQUIRES THE CHANCELLOR OF
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CONVENE A STAKEHOLDER WORK GROUP
TO DISCUSS RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ALLEVIATE CONCERNS ABOUT
<c.blue>MERGENCY RESPONSE PROGRAMS ON</c>
THE CSU CAMPUSES REPORT FINANCED
THE LEGISLATURE THIS INCLUDES
EVALUATING REPORTING PROCEDURES
AND PROCESSES. OR RESPONDED TO
NONVIOLENT AND NON CRIMINAL
SITUATIONS ON CSU CAMPUSES AND
ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
OPTIONS TO RESOLVE EMPLOYEE
CONFLICTS- MINOR INDOOR BUBBLE
COST TO SEE ISSUE CONVENE THE
WORKGROUP I ASKED WE ARRIVE OUT
. THANK YOU I WILL LOOK TO
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM FOR
SUPPORT IT'S A NON WILL TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES PHONE OPERATOR
SUPPORT. SEVEN ONLINE. AND ARE
YOU READY FOR LINE THREE FORTY
SIX WE ARE THANK. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GLORIA GARNER OF
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT. WE'LL LOOK TO
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM
SAY NONE ON OPERATOR OPPOSITION
ONLINE. THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN
NYC YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
OF THIS BILL ENTERED ENJOYS TO
DO PASSES- MOTION. THEN MOVED IS
OUR SECOND AND SECONDED. OF THE
BILLS OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT ON SB SIX THIRTY TWO
FOUR MISTER PORTANTINO.
WELL IT HERE IS MAKING ITS WAY
DOWN WILL THERE BE A MOTION
ENTERTAINED BY THE CHURCH THE
MOTION BY MR QUIRK IN THE
SECOND. ROW. MISTER CHAIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU LESTER
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES OF THIS
BILL WOULD APPROPRIATE
APPROXIMATELY FOUR AND A HALF
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD
FOR THE PAYMENT OF FIVE STATE
CLAIMS RELATED TO THE HEIRONEOUS
CONVICTIONS OF GEORGE SOUL IN
THE LATEST. A GUY MILES JOHN
KLINE EDWARD DUMBRECK DUMBRECK
AND JONATHAN HAMPTON THE NEED TO
THE HEIRONEOUS CONVICTION CASES
THE COURT SET ASIDE THE
CONVICTIONS AND GRANTED HABEAS
RELIEF. THE BOARD HAS APPROVED
EACH OF THEIR CLAIMS FOR
COMPENSATION AND RECOMMENDS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED AN
APPROPRIATION TO COVER THEIR
PAYMENTS. I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO ADDRESS US IN. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WATCHING TO
ADDRESS US IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR YOU HAVE ANYONE
THAT WISHES TO ADDRESS US IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN
Q. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN Q.
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS THOSE NUMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. THING NO QUESTIONS I
BELIEVE THIS GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AND MR
FONG VOTING I. REGULATIONS
MISTER CHAIR.
WELL NOW GIVE A MEMBERS WHO HAD
NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO DO SO. I
DON'T THE CONSENT COREA COREA I. VINCE FONG ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I.
OKAY I THINK THAT THAT COVERS
THIS OF THE CONSENT ERDOGAN'S
WILL NOW TURN TO THE- MATTER
SECRETARY TO READ TAKE UP THE
SUSPENSE FILE. CALENDAR IF YOU
WILL AND PLEASE READ THOSE THOSE
THAT ARE ON THE SUSPENSE
GALLAGHER. ONLY BILLS ON SUSPEND
SORROW ASSEMBLY BELLS. AB FIFTY
NINETY FIVE QUIRK-SILVA SIXTEEN
HUNDRED WIND SIXTEEN OH SIX ROMA
SIXTEEN FIFTEEN TANKS SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE GIPSON SIXTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN RAMA SIXTEEN THIRTY ONE
FOR THE- FORTY THREE ROBERT
RIVAS SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE JONES
SAWYER. SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE SAY
AUTO SIXTEEN SEVENTY THREE SAY
AUTO SIXTEEN EIGHTY FOUR VOEPEL
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BRIAN
SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX BRIAN SIXTY
NINETY ONE MEDINA SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN WARD SEVENTEEN TWENTY
ONE RODRIGUEZ SEVENTEEN TWENTY
FOUR STONE SEVENTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT OUR- ONE HOLE THAT.
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX MEDINA
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WARD
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AGILA
CURRY SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
LEVINE SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR
GIPSON. SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN
WEBER SEVEN EIGHTEEN OH ONE IS
THERE IN EIGHTEEN OH SIX THOMAS
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN IS THERE IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY ARAMBULA EIGHTEEN TWENTY
ONE PATTERSON EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SIX MAIENSCHEIN EIGHTEEN
FOURTEEN THIS AREA EIGHTEEN
FORTY FOUR MEDINA EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT QUIRK-SILVA EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE LEVINE EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE
BRIAN EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE- IN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE BANDITS
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE MATHIS.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ARAMBULA
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN WICKS
NINETEEN OH FOUR GRAYSON
NINETEEN TEN CRISTINA GARCIA
GARCIA NINETEEN TWELVE BONTA
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN THE V.
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE FRIEDMAN
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR RODRIGUEZ.
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX ROMMEL'S
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE GABRIEL
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE FONG
NINETEEN NINETY NINE ARAMBULA.
TWENTY OH ONE GRAYSON TWENTY OH
THREE MIKE FONG TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WICKS TWENTY TWENTY TWO
RAMOS TWENTY FORTY ONE EDUARDO
GARCIA TWENTY FORTY THREE JONES
SAWYER TWENTY FORTY FIVE JONES
SAWYER TWENTY FIFTY ONE
CUNNINGHAM TWENTY FIFTY THREE
LEE TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
QUIRK-SILVA TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN
CORREA. TWENTY SIXTY ONE TEN
TWENTY SIXTY FOUR- IN. TWENTY
SIXTY ONE TWENTY SIXTY NINE BE
APPROVED WA TWENTY SEVENTY SIX
THREE OF US TWENTY EIGHTY TWO
ROBERT RIVAS. TWENTY EIGHTY
SEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS TWENTY
NINETY ARAMBULA TWENTY NINETY
THREE MATHIS TWENTY ONE OH SIX
ROBERT RIVAS. TWENTY ONE OH
EIGHT ROBERT RIVAS TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE- IN TWENTY ONE FORTY
MURATSUCHI TWENTY ONE FORTY ONE
EDUARDO GARCIA TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE COULD BE A TWENTY ONE
FIFTY LACKEY TWENTY ONE FIFTY
TWO SMITH TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE
BRIAN TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO
WEEKS TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE
STONE TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
KWOK. WENT TO ONE EIGHTY NINE
FRIEDMAN TWENTY ONE NINETY- IN
TWENTY TWO OH FOUR
BOERNER HORVATH TWENTY TWO OH
SEVEN MCCARTY TWENTY TWO TEN
QUOTE TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN
CRISTINA GARCIA TWENTY TWO
FIFTEEN BLANCA RUBIO TWENTY TO
TWENTY MURATSUCHI TWENTY TWO
THIRTY SEVEN FRIEDMAN TWENTY TWO
THIRTY NINE MAIENSCHEIN TWENTY
TWO FORTY THREE EDUARDO GARCIA
TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN BLOOM.
TWENTY TWO FORTY EIGHT EDUARDO
GARCIA. TWENTY TWO FIFTY ONE
CALDERON TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO I
GALA CURRY TWENTY TWO FIFTY
THREE BONTA TWENTY TWO FIFTY
NINE BERMAN TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
THREE WEEKS TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT KALRA TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
THREE. GALLAGHER TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FOUR GABRIEL TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN STONE TWENTY TWO
NINETY FOUR JONES SAWYER TWENTY
THREE OH FIVE GRAYSON TWENTY
THREE OH SIX COOLEY. TWENTY
THREE OH NINE FRIEDMAN TWENTY
THREE THIRTEEN BLOOM TWENTY
THREE FOURTEEN PETRIE-NORRIS
TWENTY THREE THIRTY ONE CALDERON
TWENTY TWO THIRTY SIX FRIEDMAN.
TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE WEBER
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR FRIEDMAN
TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX GABRIEL
TWENTY THREE FIFTY GRAYSON
235-017-2360 TWO MULLIN TWENTY
THREE SIXTY FOUR. MEGAN DOLLY.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FIVE
PATTERSON TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN MURATSUCHI TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA.
TWENTY FOUR OH THREE BENNETT
TWENTY FOUR TWELVE THE
VALLAPUDUA TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN
KALRA TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN BRIAN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO MCCARTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR BLANCA
RUBIO. TWENTY FOUR FORTY OAN
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY VALLADARES
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY ONE WERE
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE ME UPON
TO TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN
RODRIGUEZ. TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
NINE MORE TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX
GABRIEL TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX
PETRIE-NORRIS TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED ARAMBULA. TWENTY FIVE OH
NINE FONG TWENTY FIVE TEN
BENNETT TWENTY FIVE TWELVE BLUE
TWENTY FIVE FIFTEEN HOLDEN
TWENTY FIVE SIXTEEN AGYLLA CURRY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR KALRA.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT BIGELOW
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR BRIAN
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE EDUARDO
GARCIA TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
GIPSON. TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX
NECESSARY IN TWENTY FIVE FORTY
NINE VIA BONTA TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
ARAMBULA TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE
GRAYSON TWENTY FIVE FIFTY FOR A
DOLLAR TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SIX.
CALDERON TWENTY FIVE SIXTY NINE
WHEN TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE BAO
K. ON. TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
BIGELOW TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY NINE
THAT IT TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
BERMAN TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE
SANTIAGO. TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX
LOW TWENTY FIVE OH SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
TEN FRIEDMAN TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN
ROBERT RIVAS TWENTY SIX TWENTY
ONE. HELLO DERIS TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN BAO QUE HAN TWENTY
SIX TWENTY EIGHT REYES TWENTY
SIX THIRTY TWO HOLDEN. TWENTY
SIX THIRTY THREE COOLEY TWENTY
SIX THIRTY SIX BERMAN TWENTY SIX
THIRTY NINE QUOTE TWENTY SIX
FORTY FIVE. RODRIGUEZ TWENTY SIX
FORTY NINE CRISTINA GARCIA
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FOUR LACKEY
265-016-2660 SEVEN FRIEDMAN
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY. TWO FLOOR A
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN GABRIEL
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ARAMBULA
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO GRAY
TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE BOARD.
TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN
ANGULAR CURRY. TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED MCCARTY TWENTY
SEVEN OH THREE MURATSUCHI TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY VIA PUT WHAT TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE QUIRK-SILVA.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY MERE BONTA
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY TWO WOULD
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY A- DONNA
TWENTY SIX. SEVEN SEVENTY THREE
HOLDEN TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
QUIRK-SILVA. TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT MCCARTY TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY THREE MURATSUCHI
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN
PETRIE-NORRIS TWENTY EIGHT OH
FIVE BOTH OUR QUE HAN. TWENTY
EIGHT TEN ARAMBULA TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTEEN BERMAN 281-610-2819
COOLEY TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE
LOW TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY THREE-
IN. TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY FOUR KEY
HIGHLY TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SEVEN CRISTINA GARCIA
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THREE
RODRIGUEZ TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR KALRA TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA. TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY EIGHT SANTIAGO
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY NINE MIA
BONTA TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY BERMAN
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY ARAMBULA.
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN
EDUARDO GARCIA TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT AGILA CURRY.
288-310-2880 FIVE PETRIE-NORRIS. TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE
ARAMBULA TWENTY NINE OH THREE
EDUARDO GARCIA TWENTY NINE TEN
SANTIAGO TWENTY NINE FORTY FOUR
PETRIE-NORRIS TWENTY NINE FIFTY
ONE SALAS. TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO
GABRIEL TWENTY NINE FIFTY THREE
SALAS TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE
COMMITTEE- WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE. TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
SIX COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
OF THE SUSPENSE CALENDARS DEEMED
APPROVED WILL NOW MOVE TO.
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW THAT WE
FINISHED OUR- A PUBLIC HEARING
ON BILLS WERE PRESENTED TODAY
WILL TAKE UP. OPEN UP THE
HEARING TO COMMENTS BY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ON ANY BILL NOT
PRESENTED TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY
PLEASE BE SURE TO LIMIT YOUR
CONTENT COMMENTS YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION. IF ANY AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. OF FIRST
TAKE UP ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
- PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THIS APPROACH SOMEONE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE
WEST ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
ZERO FIVE THREE LEVY THE- SOCIAL
HOUSING ACT THANK YOU. C. KNOWN
AS A. ONE OTHER. RACHEL GATES I
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I'M
NOT SURE IF I ESS UP THERE'S A
LOT OF BILLS DID YOU GUYS HERE
TO FIVE EIGHT FOUR. THANK.
RECALL ELECTIONS. ARE YOU NOT
ALLOWED TO ANSWER ME. I'M SORRY
NO YOU DIDN'T HEAR OKAY SO I
OPPOSE THAT WENT TO SUSPEND SO
IT'S SO IT'S A OKAY ACTUALLY. I
AM TWO THREE SIX FOUR SUPPORT
YEAH I KNOW THAT. AM TWO FIVE
FIVE THREE SUPPORT. TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE OPPOSE. WE DID DO
YOU WANT- TO- TWO SIX FIVE FOUR
SUPPORT. I'M REALLY GLAD I TOOK
NOTES BECAUSE THIS IS VERY
CONFUSING. I'M WE DID NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR YEAH. THANK YOU FOR
ENTERTAINING RIGHT NOW I'M
SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN SUPPORT.
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE SUPPORT. AND
THEN IF WE DO SIXTEEN THIRTY
THREE IF NOT SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR-
TAKING GOOD NOTES. OKAY
APPRECIATE THAT SO WE'LL TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES TO TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES. THE
PHONE OPERATOR REPUBLICAN YES
THERE WILL GO TO THE FIRST
COMMENT ONLINE ONE FORTY NINE.
AIRLINES OPEN. THANK YOU JACQUI
KERR ALAMEDA COUNTY- AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN I KNOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
OH FOUR ONE OH FOUR. HELLO GUEST
THAT ME YES IT IS. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS AMBER PLAY THEN AND- I
WANTED TO VOICE MY OPPOSITION
FOR AB ONE SEVEN NINE SEVEN THE
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY GO. AND
THEN EXPLAIN IS. ONE SIXTY SIX.
I OPPOSED. TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR. AND LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE.
MR SHARE THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING FEELS CERTAIN
COMPANY HOWARD AHMANSON JUNIOR-
WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY TWO
FOURTEEN CRISTINA GARCIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB. TWENTY SIX
FIFTY SIX TEN. AND LINE ONE
EIGHTY THREE. YES MY NAME IS
FRANCESCA WANDER I AM A MEMBER
OF INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRONG INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
INDIVISIBLE YELLOW AND
INDIVISIBLE SAN FRANCISCO WE ARE
ALL STRONG SPONSORS AND
SUPPORTERS. TWO ZERO FIVE THREE
SOCIAL HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT
. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT ONE ONE
EIGHTY. MY ONE EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED. MISTER
TURN MEMBERS MICHAEL IN BEHALF
ABOUT SPUR AND CALIFORNIAN BEEP
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SIX TANG A MEASURE
RELATED TO HOW THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT THANK YOU.
NINE TWO ZERO TWO TWO OH TWO.
THAT MEANS YES IT IS- I WANNA
POSE AS SHE ONE SEVEN NINE SEVEN
AND SB TWO ZERO NINE ON THE
CALL. CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. WINE
Q. FOR. YES STEPHANIE'S LAYLA
AND I'M CALLING BECAUSE AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN AND ALSO
AB TWENTY FIVE IMPORTANT IN YOUR
OLD LAW IT SHOULD NOT BE CHANGED
. AND OUR NEXT QUESTION OR
COMMENT COMES FROM WANTING TO-
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CLEANED C. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT QUIRK-SILVA
AS OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST EMAIL VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU. LINE. TWO SIXTEEN. HELLO
BOPPERS HE- ARTICLE I SPOKE OUR
LEAD I AM FINE I AFTER IN
TONIGHT IN FACT MEDICARE WE ARE
I AM EACH CHAPTER AND A WEEK
FROM TO PAY EIGHTY TWO FROM SIX
OR AMERICAN THREE THIRTY Q. I
THINK THREE PM WHERE RED OP
PARKWAY ARE COOL CLEAN UP OUR
ACT I BELIEVE IF CALL- WE ARE
OPPOSED AND WOULD LIKE TO ASK
ABOUT THANK YOU THANK YOU PHONE
UPPER. IF WE COULD TAKE A PAUSE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR JUST A
MOMENT WE HAVE A MEMBER THAT
NEEDS TO ADD ON TO CONSENT AND
THEN WILL RESUME. PUBLIC COMMENT
ONLY. VINCE FONG. AND FONG I ON
THE CAN CALENDAR. BOB BETTER
PHONE OPERATOR WILL CONTINUE
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT. RIGHT WILL
OPEN LINE UP Q. ZERO SIX. HELLO
THIS IS JOHN HELLO THIS IS JOHN
CAN GO WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. LINE. TWO TWENTY THREE. HI
GOOD MORNING- CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CARRY ONLY WITH ECONOMIC
SECURITY PROJECT ACTION CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
NINE TO CREATE A MINIMUM CAL
YANKEE C. AND A TWO THOUSAND
DOLLAR CHILD TAX CREDIT THANK
YOU. TWO FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WEREN'T SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN STONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
GABRIEL IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY TWO WICKS. ONE OF AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE SCREEN
FRIEDMAN. AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR WICKS.
WERE IN SUPPORT AND SPONSORS OUT
AT TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO HOLDEN
. IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY THREE COOLEY. AND THAT'S
ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
TWO SIX TWO TWO SIXTY TWO. I ONE
MOMENT WALL BUT NOT LINE UP
AGAIN TWO SIX TWO. THANK YOU
CINDY TUCK WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
AQUA HAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK WE URGE
THAT THE BILL BE HELD ON
SUSPENSE. LINE Q. EIGHTY EIGHT
I'M SURE- NO YOU EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. WELL YEAH
ON BEHALF OF. OKAY IF YOU WERE
RIGHT YOU ALSO IF YOU CANCEL. IN
A POSITION OF BEING- AND ONE
SEVEN NINE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
ONE. I VERY I HAVE A BOAT IN THE
JUST FIFTY FOUR AND I WOULD TO
REMOVE FROM THE SYSTEM CALLUM OF
A B. EIGHTEEN I WOULD LIKE TO A
ON THE PLEASE THANK YOU. LINE.
THREE FIFTEEN. ONE THREE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINES OPEN. EIGHTY TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT MY NAME IS LAURA
ROSENBERGER HYDRATION FRESNO I
ALSO TOLD AB. ONE SEVEN NINE
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE NINE NINE THREE
AND A. B. TWO. SIX THREE THREE.
THANK WHINEY. THREE TWENTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING CINDY FOWLER MONEY
OUT VOTERS IN WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. NINE THREE THIRTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING THIS IS GIL
DELL HANNAH WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED AND
LEFT A MESSAGE TO BILLS AB
TWENTY ONE OO EIGHT. RIVAS AND
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE
CREATIVE YOU FELT COLD THE MAN
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE LINE. THREE FIVE THREE
THIRTY FIVE. HI MY NAME'S
COMMITTEE HOLIDAYING I'M CALLING
TO OPPOSE AB. TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR. LINE THREE THIRTY SIX.
HELLO MY NAME IS HEATHER
HUMANISM CALLING FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK'S DISTRICT
AND I'M ASKING THEM TO OPPOSE AB
ONE SEVEN NINE SEVEN THANK YOU.
NINE THREE THIRTY EIGHT. HELLO
HAPPY FRIDAY WITH CHANGE BEGINS
WITH ME WEARING STRONG SUPPORT
AT EIGHT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AND
AB TWO ZERO FOUR FIVE THREE WCW
ON THE FLOOR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LINE THREE FORTY Q. THREE FOUR
TWO. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO
WE CAN'T. MY NAME IS DR TERESA
PALMER ON AN INDIE GERIATRICIAN
AND THE DAUGHTER OF A NOW DID
NURSING HOME PATIENTS AND I WORK
AS A VOLUNTEER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ESSENTIAL CARE GIVERS
COALITION- STRONG SUPPORTER OF
GOOD RESIDENT DESIGNATED A
SUPPORT PERSON SPELL AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SIX THE COSTS HAVE
BEEN VASTLY OVER ESTIMATED IN
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS. AND I
ASK THAT THIS BE CONSIDERED
ISOLATION KILLS. AND THIS BILL
WILL SAVE LIVES BETWEEN THE
PASSAGE THANK YOU. LINE. THREE
FORTY SIX. HI THERE MY NAME IS
THE STORY OF BERNARD I'M CALLING
FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY I AM A
MOTHER AND- I AM ASKING YOU TO
PLEASE OPPOSE AB TWO ZERO NINE
EIGHT AND AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN PREVIEWS PROTECT PARENTS
RIGHTS IN CALIFORNIA PLEASE
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO PRACICE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THEIR
CONVICTIONS- PARTICULARLY
NATURAL PASSED- THANK YOU- THE
CONSCIOUS NAME OR ARE YOU ADDING
ANOTHER BILLS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO. YES PLEASE OPPOSE THOSE
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT IN SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND THE NEXT LINE IS THREE FORTY
EIGHT. SHAREHOLDERS THE MEMBERS
CAROLINE FOWLER AND THE SIXTY
TWO CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
FOR CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
MONEY MOVE MONEY OUT VOTERS AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND REQUESTING A FLOOR
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH. NINE IF. THREE FIFTY SEVEN. THREE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN. WE'LL GO
TO LINE. THREE FIFTY NINE. YEAH
THE NICKEL MELBY FROM L. A.
COUNTY AND I'M CALLING TO URGE
YOU TO OPPOSE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN AB TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT AND AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. AND LINE THE
THREE SIXTY ONE. NINE THREE
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINES OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS BORING HATELEY WITH
THREE BILL CALIFORNIA DOT COM
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN CAN I ASK
DID YOU GUYS JUST BETTER
POSTPONED YES A. B. TWO FIVE
EIGHT FOUR I HAVEN'T HEARD IT
YET TODAY AND I AM IN OPPOSITION
. PROBABLY ON THE SUSPENSEFUL.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE. THREE SIX
TWO THREE SIXTY TWO. HI I HAVE A
RECALL AMERICA CALLING FROM
ORANGE CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF TWO
BOYS STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN AB TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT AND AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU- LINE.
ONE HUNDRED. CHRIS WITH- CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN NOW. OKAY CHRIS
I'M A- LET'S OF HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF LAW IN A RETIRED DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL JUST CALLING TO
VOICE MY OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
THIRTY SIX THE- TO CHANGE THE
NAME OF FACED IN COLLEGE LAW. I
DID SUBMIT WRITTEN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE. ONE
TWENTY SIX. HELLO MICHELLE
BETTER WITH MONEY OUT VOTERS IN
WEIRD BEING SPONSORED AB
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE STOCK
MARKET INFLUENCE IN CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS ACT AND WE WOULD URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO ADVANCE THIS TO
APPLAUD THAT THANKS SO MUCH.
LINE. ONE TWENTY NINE. I'M ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINES OPEN.
WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. HIKATHLEEN COMMENTS KERN
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE. SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN AND TWENTY NINETY
ONE THANK YOU. NINE ONE NINETY
NINE. HELLO HELLO HI AM I ON
RIGHT NOW. YES YOU ARE- JEEZ
OKAY ELIZABETH COUNTY OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA FROM THE BAND
HAMMERLOCK IN MONTHS AGAINST
OVER REACHING HANDS WE OPPOSE AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. NINE TWO
ZERO FIVE TWO OH FIVE. COOL FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL GO TO
THE NEXT LINE TO TWENTY EIGHT.
HELLO MY NAME IS FEATURING JOHN
AYE OPPOSED AB TWO ZERO NINE
EIGHT AB ONE SEVEN NINE SEVEN A.
B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. AND AB. TWENTY NINETY ONE. LINE THREE
THIRTY NINE. HI. YES I'M LISA
CALLING FROM ORANGE COUNTY I'D
LIKE TO STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN. LINE
THREE SIXTY THREE. MY NAME IS
RENEE ROMERO CALLING FROM
PHONING FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY I
OPPOSE AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN
. LINE THREE SIXTY FIVE. HI
CHAIR- TO FINISH THE MINUTES
WITH GRACE AND GIACOBBE
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
NINE ALSO PROVIDING A MEETING
FOR YOUNG INVINCIBLE CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NINE THREE
SIXTY SEVEN. YOUR TURN MEMBER
SYLVIA SO LEAST SHOT ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO THREE
THREE SIX BY FRIEDMAN AND I'M
ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO FIVE FIVE ZERO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE YEAH. THIRTY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS THE COOPER
STARTED STRONG OPPOSITION A. B.
TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT YOU SHOULD
ALWAYS BE ALLOWED TO GET A
SECOND OPINION AND I'M ALSO
OPPOSED AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN VERY HAVE REGISTERED WE
DON'T NEED MORE BROAD REGISTRY.
OKAY ARE NEXT LINE IS. THREE
SEVEN THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON DANA
FOR ON BEHALF OF MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN REGARDS
AB TWO SIX THREE NINE WE ARE A
POTENT LEFT AND ENDED PLEASE
HOLD ON. NINE THREE SEVEN FOUR
THREE SEVENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CAROLYN JENSEN
ON BEHALF THE MOJAVE WATER
AGENCY AND WESTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT- WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ON A. B.
TWO SIX THREE NINE THANK YOU.
THREE SEVEN FIVE. HELLO MY NAME
IS LUIS RIVERA WHOSE SOCIAL
EQUITY OPERATOR AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SOCIAL
EQUITY LA A NONPROFIT SERVING
LOS ANGELES- I WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE ZERO TWO
AND A. B. TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR- AS WELL AS OPPOSED AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE DEVISE IN
THE STREET MORE THAN IT HELPS.
THANK YOU. THE LINE. THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARED MEMBERS THIS IS CALLED
HOLY ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
METROPOLITAN AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO EIGHT THREE
SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA THANK YOU. WHY NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY. HELLO MY NAME IS
GREG LOPEZ FROM COMEDIC RECORD
BY YES I AM CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
ONE AB TWENTY TWO FORTY EIGHT
AND A B. TWENTY NINE OH THREE
ALL FROM THE MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA. THANK YOU. LINE. THREE
EIGHTY ONE. HI HOLLY MOSHER FROM
MONEY OUT VOTER THAN IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. NINE
THREE EIGHTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS SAID NOT SURE WHAT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION I WE HAVE SPONSORS OF
AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE JONES
SAWYER AND SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTEEN RUBIO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A BILL TO BE REMOVED
FROM THE COMMISSION SPENT FILE.
THANK YOU. LINE. TWO THIRTY SIX.
TWO TO THIRTY SIX LINES OPEN
HELLO. HELLO HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
. WE CAN. SORRY ABOUT THAT I AM
I AM MY NAME IS CINDY FOR OFFICE
I AM CALLING TO OPPOSE AB.
SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN AND ALSO
AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT- THERE IS
SOMETHING CALLED. THE PATIENTS
ACT AND A PATIENT IS ALLOWED A
SECOND OPINION SO I'M NOT
EXACTLY SURE WHY SOME OF THESE
BILLS ARE. BEING PRESENTED- A WE
DO HAVE RIGHTS AND A SECOND
OPINION SOMETHING THAT I THINK
WE JUST TAKING NAME.
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE THREE FIFTY SEVEN. THREE
FIFTY FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINES
OPEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MRS
CLINTON LEVACK ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH POLLUTION
ADVOCACY. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN AND AB
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
NINE THREE EIGHTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON TERM MEMBERS THOMAS
GARCIA WITH AND LOCAL GROUPS. ON
THE OF MARK CITY OF ROSEVILLE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ON H. B.
SKINNER TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU. NINE THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT. HELLO THIS IS JOHN
CONTRACT THE HANCOCK WITH AND
EMERALD SAUDI I CANNABIS DIDN'T
APPROPRIATIONS AND WE AB TWO
THREE NINE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
A. NINE I EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES. NINETY MY NAME IS
MELANIE TAYLOR STARK. I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF. I'VE BEEN HOLDEN
AND I AM CALLING TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX MY HUSBAND
PASSED IN A NURSING HOME DUE TO
FAILURE TO THRIVE A STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL. LINE. THREE
NINETY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHNNY DAHLE PLANE HI
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO CANNABIS RETAILERS
ALLIANCE AND WE'RE CALLING TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE
. LINE AT THREE NINETY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ROB GOAL OKAY ON YOUNG-
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOURTEEN
DELEGATES. SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWO ZERO
FIVE THREE BY SIMPLY BEVERLY
THANK YOU. LINE THREE NINE SEVEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON- REINER JACKING
WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY CALLING IN IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY NINE O'CLOCK UNLESS
AMENDED. THANKS THE LINE. TWELVE
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SALIM
FROM SALMON DINO COUNTY RIVER
THAN IN UPLAND PARENTS FOR
CHANGE AND FREEDOM AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TENTY NINETY
EIGHT AND AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE FORTY FOUR. LINE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS JOSH
SHAW WITH SHAW YOUR INTUITION
ELTERN LYING FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
MAYOR LONDON BREED IN SUPPORT OF
THE SAFETY DEMONSTRATION PROGRAM
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AB
TWO THREE THREE SIX THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
ISABEL ARE QUITE ON BEHALF OF
INFILL PROPERTIES HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IN THE
QUALITY OF THE PARTY AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SIXTEEN IN HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS PARTY BE
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE FRIEDMAN
THANK YOU. LINE. FIFTY THREE.
HERE AGAIN FROM THE NIGHT
ALAMEDA COUNTY I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION- ASSEMBLY THEY'LL
SEVENTY NINETY SEVEN AND
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. NINE SIX FIVE. HELLO MY
NAME IS SWATI SHARMA I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
NAIL SALON COLLABORATIVE AND
STOP EIGHTY P. I HATE IN AS CO
SPONSORS AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FIVE FOUR NINE THANK YOU
. LINE SIXTY SEVEN. ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN. HI IT'S
NOT ME YES IT IS- GOOD- WELL I
OPPOSE I. SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN
AND I DEFINITELY OPPOSE THE
BERMAN BILL TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR- I OFFICIALLY OPPOSED ONE
BERMAN AWARENESS AT CALIFORNIANS
NOT REALLY. WITH THE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL NOTHING BEYOND THAT AND
WILL BETTER LINES SEVENTY Q.
SHAREHOLDING THE MEMBERS JAMES
R. O. ON BEHALF OF A CALIFORNIA
MORE THINGS RIGHT AND TAKE YOUR
DIVISION OPPOSED AB TWENTY FOUR
NINE SIX PETRIE-NORRIS THANK YOU
. AND LINE NUMBER. FOUR HUNDRED.
HI DAVID MERRITT WITH THAT KINGS
RIVER CONSERVATION DISTRICT IN
REGARD TO AB TWO SIX THREE NINE
IMPOSE THE LST AMEND AND HOLD
IN SUSPENSE THANK YOU. AND LINE
NUMBER NINETY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MICHAEL LASSELL ACCORDANCE
THE OPPORTUNITY AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE
EIGHT NINE THANK YOU. AND LINE.
ONE SIXTY SIX. YES MY NAME IS
LINDA AND I'M WITH THE PAST
ACCOUNTING WE CALL GREAT BY
OPPOSED. TO EIGHTY TWO FIVE
EIGHT FOUR. 771-337-2636. TWO
TWO FIVE TWO FOUR FIVE. TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT THANK YOU. AND THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS MR CARE. THANK YOU HE- CONCLUDED OUR
BUSINESS FOR TODAY THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED.